Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Der Studio ist voller Leute, die verzeifelt versuchen, ihren Computer irgendwie ins Netz zu bringen. Mit der Ansammlung koffeinhaltiger Getränke, die hier irgendwie am Start sind, könnte man wahrscheinlich eine Kleinstadt versorgen. Niemand weiß so genau, was in den nächsten zwei Stunden passiert wird. Und es ist der letzte Donnerstag im Monat. Das bedeutet natürlich, es ist Chaosradio. Dazu herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich versuche den Rest der Meute hier im Zaum zu halten. Der Rest der Meute, das sind heute Friedrich Lindenberg, Michael Hörz und Wetter Frosch. Herzlich willkommen und guten Abend alle teilnehmenden Personen hier im Studio. Oder heißt es Lebensform? Man weiß es nicht so genau. Hallo, ist da jemand? Also nur zwei von drei waren das. Einer fehlt ja noch. Ah, das ist der Typ, den ich nicht höre. Das ist Wetter Frosch, der vor der Sendung meinte, das ist ja total einfach, man muss so einen Knopf drücken und dann ist das Mikro an.
Einen von den beiden? Ah, ich bin in der Richtung.
Genau, das nächste Mal mach ich das wieder selber. Aber wir sind ja heute nicht hergekommen, um verschiedene Knöpfe zu drücken, obwohl das möglicherweise auch eine Rolle spielen sollte, denn es ist heute natürlich so wie immer am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Es geht um ein ganz bestimmtes Thema. Und vom Chaos Computer Club selber ist nur Wetter Frosch hier. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal.
Guten Abend, genau. Ich habe angeschleppt, wie du sagtest, Michael und Friedrich, aus dem OpenData-Bereich. Da geht es um offene Daten, das ist unser Thema heute.
Okay, das klären wir gleich, bevor wir aber das machen. Lieber Michael, lieber Friedrich, was macht ihr denn sonst, wenn ihr nicht gerade über OpenData, von dem wir noch gar nicht wissen, was es ist, redet?
Also ich bin ansonsten vor allem Online-Redakteur. So vieligerweise ungefähr 5 Laufminuten von einem Studio.
So viel zum Thema Full Disclaimer, das habe ich vorher auch nicht gewusst.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nee, ich bin hier tatsächlich mit einer Hauptfunktion Online-Redakteur beim RBW und um OpenData kümmere ich mich sozusagen ehrenamtlich privat.
Ich habe grob das was anderes machen aufgegeben, aber jetzt im Prinzip für eine Non-Profit-Organisation, die Open Knowledge Foundation an Open Data-Objekten verschiedener Art und nebenbei noch im Liquid Democracy EV an Autocracy einer Politikbeteiligungssoftware.
Liquid Democracy und Autocracy und die ganzen Sachen gab es glaube ich schon zwei Chaos Radios zu oder ein Chaos Radio und einen Blue Moon auf jeden Fall. Heute geht es um Open Data. Die einfache und planloseste Frage ist natürlich Open Data, hä? Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Also Open Data ist sozusagen ganz grob die Idee, dass man Daten offen, für frei, für jeden verfügbar, für jeden nutzbar im Internet zur Verfügung stellt.
Moment mal, was mit unserer Privatsphäre?
Ach ja, es gibt natürlich Ausnahmen.
Die Frage, auf die ich hinaus wollte ist, welche Daten sollen öffentlich zugänglich sein? Das sind ja nicht alle, für die ihr kämpft, sondern nur bestimmte Daten, wo ihr sagt, die sollen jetzt allen zugänglich sein, nämlich?
Also es geht prinzipiell um Regierungsdaten, um Verwaltungsdaten, um sozusagen nicht persönliche Daten, also öffentliche Daten.
Ich glaube, man kann das irgendwie negativ ausdrücken, wenn man sagt nichts, was einzelne Personen betrifft, was nicht irgendwie einen guten Grund hat, dass es rausgegeben wird, und nichts, was sozusagen die öffentliche Sicherheit gefährdet, das heißt, wo dann die Terroristen kommen.
Also ist es aber auch so, Firmen-Daten, da geht es auch nicht drum.
Naja, also zunächst mal ist die Forderung wirklich nach Daten, die sozusagen aus der öffentlichen Hand zum Beispiel finanziert wurden, der in der Stellung wir sozusagen schon bezahlt haben. Das betrifft den Staat, das betrifft aber auch zu einem großen Teil natürlich die Wissenschaft und solche Bereiche.
Auch den öffentlichen Rundfunk.
Könnte man also zusammenfassend sagen, alle Daten, die mit dem Geld des wenigen Staat geben, irgendwie erstellt und erschaffen wurden, sollen dann auch für jedermann zugänglich sein?
Ich finde das eine plausible Forderung.
Prinzipiell ja.
Auf das ist es möglich, kommen wir später zurück. Ich wollte es nur erstmal so sagen, also das ist sozusagen die grundlegende Idee.
Also eine der grundlegenden Forderungen ist genau die. Wir haben dafür bezahlt, wir wollen da auch reingucken können.
Was für Vorteile haben wir denn davon?
Na ja, es gibt verschiedene Vorteile. Das erste ist sozusagen, dass diese Daten sich dann wirklich besser zur Weiterverarbeitung eignen. Das heißt, man kann damit irgendwie interessante Dinge tun. Das eine ist, man kann damit irgendwie wirtschaftlich interessante Dinge tun. Das ist interessantere für mich persönlich, aber man kann damit irgendwie auch einen transparenteren, verständlicheren und irgendwie einen offeneren Start schaffen. Und das ist sozusagen das, was wir im Wesentlichen zu zuecken versuchen. Das heißt, einen Start, wo man wirklich versteht, was geht vor, von den ganz großen Prozessen bis runter auf die ganz, ganz kleinen Bereiche.
Also meine Idee ist prinzipiell, dass diese Form der Daten, wie sie sozusagen eine Formulierung ist, auch die maschinenlesbare Regierung oder ein maschinenlesbarer Start, dass sie letztlich unserem Zeitalter sehr viel angemessener sind. Also es geht ja nicht darum, um irgendwie ausgedruckt oder, sagen wir mal, noch mit der Schreibmaschine getippte Seiten, sondern es geht darum, dass Rechner sie lesen können, dass sie irgendwie weiterverwendbar sind.
Und da kommt dann irgendwas bei rum. Jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo ich zum ersten Mal sage, wenn ihr das eine coole Idee findet, dann könnt ihr Folgendes tun. 0331 70 97 110. Denn auch wenn so ein Chaosradio immer dafür da ist, um mal Dinge zu erklären, die möglicherweise schwer verständlich oder sogar unbekannt sind, dient es auch dazu, eure Fragen zu dem Thema zu klären. Oder wenn ihr Beispiele habt, Dinge, von denen ihr denkt, hey, das sind also Daten, die ihr startet, die wüsste ich aber auch gerne, gerne hier anrufen. Oder aber, wenn ihr schon mal ein Erfolgserlebnis damit gehabt habt, oder wenn ihr vielleicht an irgendwelche Daten rankommen wolltet vom Start und das irgendwie nicht geklappt hat, gerne hier anrufen. 0331 70 97 20. Darüber können wir natürlich auch reden. Jetzt habt ihr ja schon erzählt, also wir wollen die Daten vom Start, die der sowieso hat, und zwar mit unserem Geld gemacht. Und wir denken, wenn man die hat, dann kann man daraus coole Dinge machen. Gibt es da Beispiele?
Da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen. Also angefangen bei Anwendungen, die uns wirklich helfen, besser zu verstehen, was der Start macht, die uns erklären, wie funktioniert eigentlich wirklich unser Parlament, wie funktioniert eigentlich wirklich unsere, wohin geben wir eigentlich unser Geld aus, oder auch nur wann wird eigentlich welches Schlagloch repariert, bis hin zu Dingen, die einfach drauf aufbauen, also zum Beispiel bessere Dienste für das Wettervorhersage oder soetwas.
Ich glaube, man kann auch damit relativ leicht, vor allem natürlich mit Browsern und solchen Dingen, Beziehungen darstellen. Man kann sehen, okay, jener Abgeordnete hat vielleicht von jedem Spender besonders viel Geldempfang oder sowas. Also man kann Zusammenhänge relativ schön herausarbeiten.
Ist das in jedem Fall wünschenswert?
Nicht in jedem Fall, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube, es gibt einfach unheimlich viele Fragestellungen, für die der Staat selbst keinen Auftrag hat, sie auch irgendwie so auszuforschen. Und gleichzeitig sind sie die Einzigen, die die Informationen halten, die notwendig sind, diese Fragestellungen zu beantworten. Das heißt, wenn das passieren soll, wenn eben sozusagen mal geguckt werden soll, wie viel hat sich eigentlich das, du hast es jetzt gar gebracht, das Wahlverhalten und die Parteispenden, dann gibt es doch irgendwie eine Korrelation. Dann ist es keine staatliche Aufgabe, sie haben die besten Informationen dazu.
Beziehungsweise prinzipiell ist es ja so, dass es einfach sehr viel mehr Leute gibt, die Ideen haben. Und du sagtest gerade, Friedrich, er hat vielleicht nicht den Auftrag, vielleicht hat er auch gar nicht die Idee, was man eigentlich mit diesem Zeug machen könnte. Und da ist es einfach sehr viel sinnvoller, die Sachen prinzipiell zur Verfügung stehen zu haben, um ganz, ganz viele Leute da draußen was damit machen lassen zu können.
Das große Motto lautet dann, die coolste Sache, die man mit deinen Daten machen kann, denkt sich jemand anders aus.
Was sind denn so die coolsten Sachen? Oder was habt ihr beide, Friedrich, Michael, schon so viel Sachen gebaut, aus welchen Daten habt ihr euch beschäftigt?
Also ich hab irgendwie ein Lieblingsprojekt, das ist der offene Haushalt. Das ist sozusagen der Versuch gewesen, wofür gibt es Deutschland wirklich sein Geld aus? Was ist eigentlich im Haushalt drin? Man kennt es ja aus der Tageszeitung oder so, da gibt es immer dann, wenn der Haushalt verabschiedet wird, so ein Diagramm, da sieht man grob, ja hier Sozial, dort Verteidigung, dort Außen. Aber dann weiß man irgendwie nicht so richtig weiter. Wie geht das weiter? Was ist sozusagen die nächste Ebene? Und da haben wir versucht, eine Seite zu bauen, in der wir die ganzen Daten vom Finanzministerium, von der Webseite sozusagen eins zusammengetragen haben, die neu zusammengesetzt haben und die visualisiert Leuten zugänglich gemacht haben. Und da auf nehaushalt.de kann man dann eben sich so durchklicken, gucken, innerhalb des Verteidigungsressorts, worauf ging die Zahlung, innerhalb des Sozialressorts, worauf geht das, was ist Rente, was ist Sozialhilfe. Und das finde ich einfach eine schöne illustrative Sache.
Wir hatten auch speziell in Berlin so ein Projekt, da ging es darum, wie im vergangenen Jahr oder im vorvergangenen Jahr die Mittel für dieses Konjunkturpaket II, was ein Regenhaufen war, wie die verteilt wurden. Und man konnte dann relativ gut, letztlich auf einer Karte, also auf Google Maps oder OpenStreetMaps sehen, wo bündeln sich diese Geldenmengen. Und tatsächlich konnte man das damit so schön in großen roten Kreisen sehen. Es sind vor allem eigentlich die Gegenden gewesen, in denen es tendenziell den Leuten relativ gut ging, wo auch relativ viel investiert wurde.
Das Problem mit dieser Seite war dann ganz konkret, dass diese Daten uns nicht wirklich nutzbar gegeben wurden. Das heißt, wir haben dann ein Schreiben erhalten von der Berliner Verwaltung, dass wir dort im Prinzip ihre Urheberrechtsansprüche verletzen würden und mussten dann diese Seite löschen.
Urheberrechtsansprüche?
Ja, also das sind Geodaten und Geodaten sind in Deutschland irgendwie ein furchtbares Minenfeld. Die Frage dort ist immer, wer hat diese Daten erhoben, wer hat sie zwischendurch verarbeitet und insgesamt, was für Ansprüche könnte es darauf geben, was für Interessen hat auch sozusagen der Teil der Verwaltung, der die hält. Und wenn da irgendwo zum Beispiel eine private Firma vorkommt, dann kann man das im Prinzip ganz vergessen momentan. Und auch sonst ist es einfach unwahrscheinlich, dass man an Geodaten rankommt.
Okay, da würde ich dann gleich mal Marco abgeben, da hat er mich angerufen. Hallo Marco.
Guten Abend.
Und möchte er eine Frage stellen, die sich finde ich fast direkt daran anschließt, was du gerade gesagt hast. Marco, deine Frage bitte.
Ja genau, schließt ein bisschen daran an. Ich habe die Frage, wie wollt ihr das erreichen, dass ihr die Daten jetzt vom Startup bekommt. Wie du gerade schon gesagt hast mit dem Waiver Rechnen, ist natürlich eine Sache. Bei der Start wird es bestimmt etwas dagegen, dass ihr manche Daten oder Finanzwege freilegt für andere.
Ja, es gibt da irgendwie verschiedene Dinge. Das erste ist natürlich, Urheberrecht ist immer ein großartiges Mittel. Zum Glück haben wir in Deutschland aber auch gesetzliche Regelungen, die viele, viele Daten im Prinzip gar nicht dem Urheberrecht unterwerfen. Das zweite ist, wir müssen mit der Politik reden. Und wir müssen Argumente bringen und deutlich machen, dass es einfach peinlich ist, wenn man Dinge dadurch, dass man sie nicht rausgibt, versucht es.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel den Staat anschreibe und sage, ach hier, legt mal bitte die Daten so und so frei für euer Finanzakt von oben bis unten, damit ich dem Bürger mal zeigen kann, wo ihr Geld dann vielleicht hinfließt und wo sie noch fehlfließen, dann würde der Staat sagen, warum sollen wir euch das geben?
Zum Glück haben wir in Deutschland ein Gesetz. Also es gibt das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und das ist genau dafür da. Da kannst du einen Brief schreiben. Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, nach Informationsfreiheitsgesetz möchte ich diese Informationen. Da müssen die begründen, wieso das nicht rauszugeben ist.
Funktioniert das auch?
Vielleicht nochmal eine andere Sache, weil du sagtest, Marco gerade, die Frage ist manchmal auch gar nicht, ob der Staat total defensiv ist dabei oder sagt, er will das gar nicht. Manchmal ist es eher der Faktor, dass du einfach mal ein bisschen klarmachen musst. Pass mal auf, ihr habt da Sachen, die sind möglicherweise nach einer ziemlich veralteten Dezenz oder so oder sind überhaupt nicht zugänglich. Wollt ihr nicht? Also das ist ihm auch ein Aspekt. Das ist nicht unbedingt darum, dass du da eine Trutzburg hast und dass sich da der abstrakte Staat verschanzt dahinter. Sondern ist es auch teilweise eher ein bisschen Dialog suchen, ein bisschen informieren und sagen, wollt ihr nicht mal? Könntet ihr euch nicht vorstellen?
Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass irgendwann kennt es halt, dass der Staat doch viele Gelder in die falschen Hände gibt und dass sie in den falschen Ecken landen wollen. Und von daher, manche wollen, dass es weiterhin dahin fließt.
Redet ihr beide denn hier im Studio auch mit Politikern?
Relativ häufig.
Also da sagen die dazu... Also Marco kommt jetzt ja mit einer gewissen Skepsis und stellt die unter.
Nein, ich finde das sehr gut, was ihr da macht. Ich bin ja echt dafür, aber es ist halt die Frage, manche stehen ja dahinter und gibt darum gewissen Lobbyismus in Deutschland.
Na ja, es gibt im Prinzip von allen Parteien in Deutschland ein wirkliches Bekenntnis zu OpenData. Die Frage ist sozusagen, wer legt zuerst mal wirklich ein Ei. Also die Idee, wir wollen irgendwie wissen, was passiert, gegen die stellt sich natürlich niemand. Und im Prinzip, es gibt auch wirklich in allen Parteien aktiv Leute, die daran arbeiten, die sich dafür einsetzen.
Okay, warte, das muss also, kurzer Moment mal, es ist tatsächlich zu sagen, es gibt ein politisches Thema in Deutschland, zu dem ein breiter Konsens über alle Parteien existiert?
Sagen wir mal, ein breiter Konsens über alle Parteien wäre, vielleicht ein bisschen sehr weit gegriffen, aber es gibt eben Politiker in jeder Partei. Und es gab auch zum Beispiel bei der Gründungsversammlung des Open Data Network, gab es eine ganze Menge prominenter Politiker, die entweder persönlich oder stellvertretend da Mitglied geworden sind. Das heißt natürlich nicht von, wenn du an einen nehmen würdest, und so wie viel, 672, nein, Bundestagsabgeordnete, dass da jeder einzelne gesagt hätte, ja, ich will.
Okay, aber zu sagen, ist es diesmal nicht auszumachen, dass du eine gewisse politische Strömung mit einer gewissen Zustimmung oder Ablehnung automatisch verknüpft ist. Marco, eine Frage noch an dich. Gibt es irgendwas von diesen Daten, die du besonders interessant findest, also die du gerne wissen wolltest, wenn du die Möglichkeit hättest?
Na, was eigentlich viele wissen würden, das kann zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, wo die ganzen Mittel in Schulen fließen oder in öffentliche Vereine eben, in dem Sinne. Manche vereinen Generativheit unter, manche erleben da einen Schub, da träumt man davon.
Du meinst die Fördermittel, wie die Fördermittel verteilt werden, gibt es da schon irgendwas zu sagen?
Es gibt einen Archiv dazu, das ist der Förderkatalog. Das ist eine gemeinsame Sache, die wird hauptsächlich vom Bildungsministerium und vom Wirtschaftsministerium getrieben. Da findet man aber relativ wenig drin. Da sind gerade so die ganz großen politischen Stiftungen drin. Natürlich das Problem ist dort, dass es unheimlich zersplittert ist. Es gibt in Deutschland keine zentrale Stelle, die kontrolliert, an welchem Verein wie viel Geld gibt. Es gibt wahrscheinlich 7000 unterschiedliche Leute, die an irgendjemanden irgendwas geben können. Das ist dann verteilt über Europaebene, über Bundesebene, über die Landesebene und auch auf der kommunalen Ebene. Das alles zusammenzufügen, wenn man es machen will, was ich für ein großartiges Vorhaben halte, das kann aus dem Start heraus nicht passieren.
Aber der konnte zumindest alle, also an jeder Stelle, alle Daten offenlegen.
Das ist ja auch die Frage, meinst du jetzt Großspender oder meinst du jetzt, wenn der Staat fördert? Also das wäre nochmal die Frage, wie weit Bildungsetat verfügbar ist. Gibt es da irgendwo auch im Haushalt, wenn du sagst, du visualisierst den Haushalt, kennst du auch dieses dicke Buch an Haushalt, was vom Land Berlin Bildungslandessache rausgegeben wird, ist das befriedigend, was da aufgeschlüsselt wird?
Also man muss unterscheiden zwischen Haushaltsdaten und einzelnen Projektförderungsdaten. Und der Haushalt, der ist irgendwie von Natur aus extrem grob. Das ist sozusagen die Planung. Da haben sich irgendwelche Politiker zusammengesetzt und haben irgendwie diskutiert, was sind unsere Prioritäten für die nächste Zeit. Und das andere ist sozusagen konkret, was wurde vergeben. Das haben natürlich nicht die Politiker beschlossen, sondern irgendwelche Leute in der Verwaltung. Und diese zweite Art von Information, von der gibt es unheimlich wenig leider.
Ich meine, es gibt auf der anderen Seite, auch weil du gerade zum Beispiel sprachst von Vereinen, es gibt auf der EU-Ebene, gibt es auch von der privaten Initiative farmsubsidi.org, wo du sehen kannst, wo die ganzen Spendengäder, nicht Spendengäder, Quatsch, wo EU-Fördergäder hingehen. Und ganz interessant, wenn man sich das, zum Beispiel, man kann sich dann aufschlüsseln, das nach großen Empfängern, man kann sich das nach Ländern, Bundesländern und so weiter aufschlüsseln.
Aber eine kurze Zwischenfrage, Farmsubsidiary heißt ja irgendwie Landwirtschaft oder was?
Ja, das Interessante ist aber, da geht es auch, zum Beispiel, wenn du das runterbrichst, kriegen zum Beispiel auch Sportvereine, anscheinend aus bestimmten EU-Fördertöpfen für die Überarbeitung ihrer Sportplätze, ihrer Grünflächen anscheinend, jede Menge Geld. Da kommst du dann auch wieder bei solchen Sachen an. Weil das im weiteren Sinne EU-Landwirtschaftsförderungen sind, kommst du da auch wieder bei so einem Geld an.
Die Frage, wer entscheidet das? Welcher Verein? Wie viel bekommt das? Also, bei den Wettbewerben fließen halt wirklich manche Gelder an verschiedene in die falschen Hände.
Ich glaube, da sprechen wir jetzt von zwei unterschiedlichen Sachen. Diese EU-Landwirtschaftsinger, die sind ja an festen Regeln angeknüpft. Da gibt es einen interessanten Punkt, nämlich ob das überprüfbar ist, nach welchen Maßgaben diese Fördermittel reingebracht werden. Was du jetzt meinst, Markus, glaube ich eher, es gibt ja Fördertöpfe, da kann man sich drum bewerben. Und dann entscheidet halt irgendjemand, welche Bewerbung genommen wird oder nicht.
Ja, aber bleiben wir kurz bitte bei dem EU-Punkt.
Also nochmal, um es ganz klar zu machen, bei dem EU-Punkt geht es um landwirtschaftliche Förderung. Okay. Gut. Dann sozusagen die Frage, da gibt es ja sozusagen feste Daten, wie dieses Gelder vergeben wird. Ich gehe hin und sage irgendwie, ich habe 20 Quadratkilometer Fußballplatz und der ist grün. Und jetzt würde ich da gerne irgendwie Geld verhaben. Was bringt uns OpenData da, wo ja die Regeln eigentlich relativ feststehen?
Wir können eben wirklich erkennen, zum einen kann man eben sehen, wurden die wirklich an diejenigen vergeben, die jetzt Bedarf hatten. Also zum Beispiel einer der größten Empfänger in England von solchen Farmsubsidies ist die Queen und Prince Charles.
Die haben sie auch dringend nötig.
Ja, die haben halt viel Grünfläche. Und dann kriegen die halt auch ein bisschen Agrarsubventionen. Macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
Und einer der größten Empfänger in Deutschland sind zum Beispiel im Norden und Süden jeweils sehr große Zuckerfirmen, die nichts machen, als weißen Rübenzucker zu produzieren.
Oh ja, der war auch gut. Das müsst ihr nochmal erzählen nach irgendeiner Nummer, wo mal Daten öffentlich gelegt wurden. Da müsst ihr mal sagen, in welchem Kontext das überhaupt geschah. So Dinge auffielen, die überhaupt gar nicht plausibel sind.
Gut, aber nochmal ganz kurz. Grundsätzlich haben wir ein bisschen auch eine Definitionssache. Also viel, glaube ich, was dich interessiert, Marco, fällt nicht ganz so stark unter OpenData, sondern eigentlich eher um ein Open Government, also Entscheidungswege, offen zu legen. Das ist ein Bereich, in dem es relativ viele Überschneidungen gibt, der aber sozusagen nicht so originär mit dem, also nicht ausschließlich mit dem zu tun hat, über das wir jetzt vor allem sprechen.
Aber ist es nicht sozusagen, das hat doch noch die Grundlage, oder? Ich kann doch Open Government, also die Regierung sozusagen in dem, was sie tut, überwachen, kann ich doch nur, wenn mir auch alle Basisdaten zur Verfügung stehen.
Genau, also ich meine, dann kann man halt wirklich gucken, hat so ein Programm das bewirkt, was es sollte. Also wenn Nestle, die sind global der größte Empfänger von solchen Agrarsubventionen, wenn Nestle am Ende dann von EU-Subventionen lebt und nicht irgendwie kleine, kleine Bauern, die eigentlich davon profitieren sollten, war dann dieses Programm irgendwie wirklich erfolgreich. Und ich finde, solche Fragen beantworten zu können, und die beantworten zu können nicht nur mit irgendwelchen aus der Theorie abgeleiteten Statements, sondern mit ganz konkreten Datenbasen, das ermöglicht irgendwie eine Form von Politik, die dann auch viel sachlicher wird, und die auch meiner Hoffnung nach, oder ich gehe fest davon aus, besser ist.
Der andere Punkt ist auch bei solchen Daten, die dann zugänglich sind, du kannst sie nehmen und du kannst einfach über einen ganz anderen Einstieg reinkommen. Du nimmst eine Karte, du klickst da rein und siehst, ok, da ist dieses Unternehmen, und das verteilt sich hier so und so. Also dieser visuelle Einstieg, der Einstieg über Karten, ist relativ schlau und relativ eingängig, zugänglich.
Das ist dann der nächste Schritt, dass man versucht, die Dinge runterzubrechen auf ein Level, wo sie irgendwie zugänglicher werden.
Ok, ich wollte gerade sagen, das heißt, die Forderung ist ja eigentlich nicht nur, Daten an die Öffentlichkeit zu geben, sondern das auch noch in einem Format, mit dem wir es anfangen können. Ich würde jetzt gerne das Schlagwort eingescannte Faxe bringen. War da nicht auch irgendwas?
Ja, also eingescanntes und verpdftes und so was, das ist unser großes Problem im Prinzip. Also man kriegt unheimlich viel Information, sag ich mal, online. Es gibt unheimlich viele Informationsseiten.
Wir haben da ein PDF.
Wir haben da ein PDF. Das Problem, das muss man kurz erklären, ein PDF ist sozusagen das, was Computer machen, wenn sie so tun, als würden sie drucken. Das heißt, was am Ende in einem PDF übrig bleibt, ist sozusagen die Druckvorschlufe, da steht, schreib oben rechts das hin, schreib oben links das hin. Und das ist was ganz anderes als zum Beispiel die Daten, die man in Excel hat, wo man wirklich eine Struktur drin hat.
Aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war es doch eine Nummer bunter. Also man kann ja auch in PDF sozusagen, gibt es ja auch noch Buchstaben, die man sozusagen auch maschinell auslesen könnte. Aber es gibt wohl viele, sozusagen Regierungsstellungen, scannen Papier ein und tun das Bild dann in ein PDF. Das heißt, dann hab ich dann wirklich sozusagen...
Das gibt es zum Beispiel bei den Spenden für die Parteien im Bundestag häufig. Jede Fraktion so einen Bericht machen muss, welche Spenden sie bekommen hat und so. Und dann geben sie halt so eine Tabelle ab. Und dann geht die Bundestagsverwaltungsbehörde da hin und zieht diese Tabelle und packt die hinten ins PDF. Dann hat man da so eine krumme und schiefe Tabelle eingescannt ins PDF.
Ist sie zufälligerweise so schlecht zu lesen, ein bisschen bewischt?
Dreimal gepackt und schlecht zu lesen, genau. Das ist schon so... Das war zumindest vor einigen Jahren, da hatte ich mal so den Anhang durchscrollt, haarsträubend.
Das Knuffige daran ist, dass es mit 90% Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht Absicht ist.
Was hätte ihr denn gern? Wie müssten die Daten aussehen?
Die erste Antwort darauf ist, das, was die intern verwenden, das, was sie jeden Tag benutzen. Das ist per Definition gut genug. Sonst würde es intern nicht funktionieren.
Letztlich verwenden die, ob es jetzt was für ein Programm, die verwenden, ob es Excel, Microsoft, Excel mit vielen hohen Gebühren, die diese Verwaltung dafür bezahlen muss, oder ob es OpenOffice ist oder auch was auch immer. Prinzipiell sagt Friedrich ganz richtig, die verwenden das in einer Form, mit der sie hübsche Sachen auswerten können, sich darstellen können, was filtern können. All dieses, also in irgendeiner Form, Tabellen.
Tabellen sind gut, Formen von geografischen Gebilden sind großartig, insgesamt ordentlich formatierter Text ist großartig, all solche Sachen.
Weil der Punkt ist ein bisschen leer, es geht ja darum, letztlich, zum einen, wenn du auf der ersten, auf der Anfangsebene bist, dann guckst du dir das als Person an. Da guckst du durch ein bisschen, siehst was, scrollst du ein bisschen drüber und schaust dir an, oh, da könnte vielleicht ein Zusammenhang sein, da ist was Unregelmäßiges. Aber letztlich geht es ja um Daten im großen Stil. Das heißt, irgendwann lässt du da ein Computerscript drüber laufen oder du lässt das, du tust das auf den Server und lässt das dann auswerten oder verwenden, um das nochmal auszugeben. Also das heißt, diese Daten müssen in irgendeiner Form letztlich erst mal ohne menschliches Zutun auswertbar sein. Deswegen brauche ich maschinenlesbare, maschinenverarbeitbare Daten.
Also ihr wollt jetzt noch gar nicht mal das volle Programm. Also Hauptsache erst mal das, was da ist. So, wirklich die maschinengenau lesbaren, erfassbaren Sachen kann man dann ja immer noch später draus machen. Also das finde ich auch einen sehr pragmatischen Ansatz.
Also das ist auch manchmal schon relativ viel gefragt. Also wir haben jetzt mit Haushaltsdaten, da gibt es zum Beispiel Gemeinden, die sagen, ja cool, wir wollen irgendwie euch unsere Haushaltsdaten geben. Das Problem ist, wir haben hier so ein riesen System von SAP stehen und wahrscheinlich kommt man da nie wieder an diese Daten ran.
Und es ist dann halt großer Computer Software Hersteller, der dir irgendwas verkauft, das macht dann irgendwie...
Ja, möglicherweise ist es ein Paket-Alarm, damit SAP dann sozusagen in Zukunft auch noch an die Open Data Aktivisten ihre Systeme verkaufen kann, damit die die Daten lesen können, die die Gemeinden ihnen geben.
Die Lösung ist meistens aber viel einfacher. Da müssen die mal zu ihrem lokalen Nerd gehen. Also der Typ mit dem langen Bart, der irgendwie unten im Erdgefloss sitzt und den fragen und der weiß natürlich, dass man da irgendwie ordentliche Daten rausziehen kann. Aber die Möglichkeit wurde einfach noch nie in Betracht von dir gezogen.
Öffentlich angestellte Nerds, ihr wisst ein wenig, wie ihr euch zu wenden habt. Marco, dir ist auf jeden Fall erstmal vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Und viel Spaß noch. Wir werden uns im weiteren Fahrrad der Sendung oder gleich nach dem Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr auch mal damit beschäftigen, wie das denn jetzt genau mit den gesetzlichen Grundlagen ist. Weil da gibt es noch ein paar Grafen, mit denen man winken kann, und mit denen auch dann Kritiker gerne winken. Das klären wir gleich genau auf. Vorher gibt es noch ein kleines Stück Musik. Ich habe mich bemüht, wieder etwas dem Chaosradio Angemessenes zu finden. Es trägt den schönen Titel. Also die Musikrichtung ist 8-Bit Breakcore. Ich bin da sehr gespannt, was dahinter steckt. Die Band heißt Audio Blender und Quality from Plow ist der Titel. Also wie gesagt, ich garantiere für nichts. Aber ihr habt mir letztes Mal gesagt, 8-Bit ist cool.
Na ja, da haben wir keine Nöte.
Kommen wir zu den Datenverkehrsmeldungen. Handhelds zwischen iPhone sowie Android-Geräten und ihren Herstellern wird mehr gefunkt als angenommen und auch eure Ortungshistorie wird zurückgesendet und Interessierten bereitgestellt. Wir empfehlen dieses Feature global abzuschalten, falls es euch möglich ist. Sony-Konsolen, nachdem das Playstation-Network gehackt wurde, sind jetzt neue, schwerwiegende Gerüchte im Umlauf. Angeblich soll die Übertragung von Kreditkartendaten zwischen PS3-Konsolen und Sony-Servern komplett unverschlüsselt vorgenommen worden sein. Wir empfehlen euch eine gründliche Untersuchung eurer entsprechenden Konten. Spam-Aufkommen. Nach Abschaltung des Botnetzes Rustdoc im März ist das Gesamtaufkommen unerwünschter Werbemails kurzzeitig um rund 34 Prozent gesunken. Nach einem historischen Hoch Anfang letzten Jahres war der Trend beständig rückläufig. Mittlerweile sind aber wieder neun von zehn Mails Spam. Wir empfehlen, eure Filter stets aktuell zu halten und wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Vielen Dank, Philipp Burger.
Und wenn neue Musik im www.faitz.de. Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaos Radio, Folge 167. Es geht um OpenData und zu Gast sind hier drei Leute gleich, nämlich Wetter Frosch, der bestimmt das Mikro aufgemacht hat dieses Mal.
Hallo Friedrich. Hallo.
Und Michael.
Hallo.
Letzere beiden sind OpenData Aktivisten und OpenData bedeutet, es haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon geklärt, der Staat sammelt viele Daten, erstellt viele Daten und macht das ja eigentlich mit dem Geld, das wir ihm geben, also Steuern und was auch immer wir sonst an den Staat zahlen. Die Forderung ist also, hey, dann soll uns doch bitte die Daten auch wieder rausgeben. Das ist nicht so einfach und die OpenData Aktivisten sind im Moment auch mal damit zufrieden, dass sie die Daten einfach kriegen. Egal in welcher Form, dass die Form dann sauber wird, das klären wir dann ein andermal, sagen sie, später, wenn das alles läuft, sozusagen. Jetzt klang in der ersten halben Stunde schon an, dass es da möglicherweise rechtliche Probleme gibt. Ja, es gibt also Daten, die sind durch das Urheberrecht geschützt und deswegen darf man die nicht einfach rausgeben. Wie ist denn das insgesamt mit diesen ganzen staatlichen Daten? Gibt es nicht irgendein Gesetz, was man da machen könnte oder was es vielleicht auch schon gibt, irgendwo versteckt, wo genau das drinsteht, was ihr wollt?
Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Sachen. Es gibt zum einen das Urheberrecht und da gibt es einen Paragraph 5, der sagt im Grunde, dass alle staatlichen und amtlichen Dokumente zunächst nicht dem Urheberrecht unterliegen.
Aha, Problem gelöst.
Problem nicht so wirklich gelöst. Erstens ist natürlich die Frage, was ist eigentlich jetzt ein wirkliches amtliches Dokument und was ist irgendwie so ein Nebenprodukt? Und zum anderen gibt es auch in Deutschland zum Beispiel Datenbankrechte, das heißt ein Dokument an sich, es unterliegt vielleicht nicht dem Urheberrecht, aber dann eine gesamte Sammlung unterliegt dadurch, dass man sie zusammengetragen hat, auf einmal wieder dem Urheberrecht.
Aber wenn es der Staat tut, nicht, aber wenn der Staat mit jemandem zu tun hat, der das tut, dann haben wir wieder Probleme.
Genau und der Staat hat irgendwann in den 80ern beschlossen, dass er nicht die Kompetenz hat, Datenbanken zusammen zu tragen und hat deshalb lauter Firmen gegründet.
Hat das Argument eigentlich mal jemand bei der Vorratssatenspeicherung? Oder egal. Dafür sind sie kompetent genug. Gut, also ist es sagen, es geht also mal so oder so, ist das Urheberrecht da der einzige Stolperstein oder gibt es noch andere Paragraphen, die da gerne hochgehalten werden, wo dann Leute sagen, ja hier nach 167 Abschnitt 2, 6, die Betriebsgeheimnis. Betriebsgeheimnis?
Ja, das Betriebsgeheimnis.
Inwiefern spielt das eine Rolle?
Na ja, ich meine, was eine der spannendsten Sachen sind natürlich um Verträge, die zwischen Staat und privaten Unternehmen abgeschlossen wurden oder auch Informationen, die von privaten Unternehmen im Auftrag des Staats erhoben wurden. Und das ist alles ein Teil, der wirklich von Betriebsgeheimnissen durchsetzt dann ist.
Stichwort Berliner Wasser. Also das sind jetzt ja nicht wirklich Daten, sondern erst mal wirklich die Abmachung, um die es da geht. Was ist dazu gelaufen, was ist ihr dazu zu berichten?
Also prinzipiell waren sie tatsächlich auch genau, weil du sagtest, wirtschaftliches Geheimnis nicht zugänglich eine ganze lange Zeit. Und ich mein, wir hatten da die Initiative des Berliner Wassertisches, die über eine ganz lange Zeit Unterschriften gesammelt haben, in der ersten Form, erst für einen Was-was-Bürger-Entscheid und dann Volksentscheid, um diese Abmachungen transparent zu machen oder einsichtig zu machen. Im Prinzip lief es ja am Ende darauf raus, dass letztlich ihnen Aktivisten bzw. die Taz zuvorkamen und diese ganzen Vertragswerke und vor allem, wo es darum geht, sozusagen um den Gewinnschlüssel. Also wie viel muss die Stadt Berlin, diesen beiden großen Unternehmen, die daran beteiligt sind, also diesen Privatunternehmen, wie viel muss die den jährlich an Millionen abführen? Das war der essenzielle Punkt oder sozusagen auch die Argumentation der Aktivisten. Wenn wir das erstmal klar haben, wie viel und wie viel Geld es da gibt, dann können wir überhaupt erstmal entscheiden, was kostet ein Rückkauf oder ist ein Rückkauf möglich oder ist es möglich sozusagen auf eine Rekommunalisierung zu klagen?
Was ist denn da der Open Data Ansatz? Ist der zu sagen, also wir wollen sofort auch die Verträge haben oder ist es dann eigentlich zu sagen, ach wisst ihr Leute, die Verträge sind uns eigentlich egal? Denn ihr müsst in Zukunft sowieso alle Geldflüsse, das ist ja auch Open Data, irgendwie freilegen, dann wissen wir sowieso, was Sache ist.
Also ich meine, Open Data konzentriert sich schon stärker auf Daten, denn auf Dokumente. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen Fasi, wann irgendwie hört Datenbank auf, wann fängt Dokument an. Aber im Grunde ist das erstmal die Primärforderung, weil man damit eben auch wirklich interessante neue Dinge machen kann. Dinge, an die der Staat bisher noch nicht gemacht hat.
Aber jetzt in diesem konkreten Fall.
In diesem konkreten Fall ist natürlich der Aspekt gewesen, dass kurz bevor überhaupt die Entscheidung fiel oder die Bürger eigentlich tatsächlich sich dafür entschieden, war das Ganze offengelegt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das Ganze war. Ich glaube, da gab es doch so Nebenverträge und ich glaube, ein Teil davon war auch noch nicht wirklich dann raus.
Also sozusagen die teilvertraglichen Nebenabreden oder so schöne Formulierungen?
Ich glaube, es gab sogar Teile davon, die mündlich waren. Also ich bin da nicht hundertprozentig drin in dem Thema, aber das war irgendwie eine etwas komplexere Operation. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob bis heute irgendwie wirklich alles davon bekannt ist.
Ich meine, hier kommen wir sozusagen zu dieser essentiellen Frage, dieser Grundfrage, fahre ich eher gegen den Startansatz, also die WikiLeaks-Methode. Ich sage, ich zwinge sie zu ihrem Glück, ich veröffentliche das Ganze. Oder fahre ich eher den kooperativen Ansatz und sage, kommt, ihr wollt es doch auch.
Na, ich meine, ihr seid jetzt zwei Leute, Arbeitsteilung wäre durchaus vorstellbar oder wie ist der Ansatz dann?
Nein, ich meine, im Prinzip, du kannst natürlich Leaks machen. Das ist spannend und ich glaube, in ganz vielen Fällen ist es notwendig. Und gut, aber gleichzeitig führt es nicht zu einer grundsätzlich neuen Form des Regierens. Wenn es zu irgendwas auf Seiten der Regierenden führt, dann ist es, dass man sich zuschließt, dass man versucht, wie können wir in Zukunft vermeiden, dass unsere Daten rauskommen?
Na, aber das finde ich eine interessante Frage, weil ich gerade überlegt habe, mal angenommen, ihr setzt jetzt OpenData durch und sagt ihr so, also alle Daten, wo das geht, gebt ihr bitte ab sofort raus und dann machen sie das. Und dann gibt es aber halt irgendwie Urheberrecht und Betriebsgeheimnis gibt es ja weiterhin. Ob das dann nicht einfach dazu führen würde, dass sozusagen die Daten, die nicht rausgegeben werden sollen, dann sozusagen einfach an Dritte weitergegeben werden, weil dann kann man sie ja leider nicht mehr rausgeben.
Oder der Punkt ist ja prinzipiell, das hat ja schon einen gewissen klaren Ablauf. Und zwar ist die Idee dabei, dass ich im Prinzip einen Katalog erstelle von vorne rein. Also wenn das mal in seinem Idealfall durchgesetzt ist, ich habe einen Datenkatalog, in dem ist festgelegt, all diese Dinge müssen veröffentlicht werden. Die andere Variante wäre schöner, nur diese ganz wenigen Dinge dürfen nicht veröffentlicht werden. Aber ich habe einen Datenkatalog, da steht drin, in Zukunft muss all das veröffentlicht werden. Damit hast du dann oder ab dem Zeitpunkt, an dem ein Gesetz gilt. Und damit ist klar, alles muss raus. Und damit hast du relativ wenige, sozusagen, Ausfluchtmöglichkeiten.
Und dann muss man auch sagen, OpenData heißt nicht einfach, wir wollen, dass Dinge ins Internet kommen, sondern es soll eben unter zwei ganz zentralen Aspekten passieren. Das eine haben wir schon ein bisschen erläutert, Maschinenlesbarkeit. Das andere, was fast noch wichtiger ist, ist die Forderung nach rechtlicher Offenheit. Das heißt, was passieren muss, ist, dass Daten, wenn sie denn im Urheberrecht unterliegen, rechtlich offen bereitgestellt werden. Das heißt, offen heißt, man kann diese Daten benutzen für alles, was man will. Man kann sie kommerziell benutzen, man kann sie nicht kommerziell benutzen. Man kann sie freigeben. Es gibt ein paar Bedingungen, die man dran knüpfen kann, zum Beispiel, dass man den den den Autoren sozusagen nennen muss, den ursprünglichen, oder dass man die modifizierten Daten wieder freigeben muss. Aber innerhalb dieses Rahmens müssen die Informationen sozusagen von jedem für jeden Zweck nutzbar sein.
Aber ist denn wirklich eine kommerzielle Weiterverwendung notwendig? Oder warum fordert ihr das?
Sagen wir mal so, die kommerzielle Weiterverwendung soll eben auch genauso möglich sein. Ich glaube, man sollte jetzt nicht da den Eindruck haben, dass es hier vor allem um riesige krakenartige Unternehmen geht, die sich einen Spaß daran machen, sondern es geht, glaube ich, eher darum, dass es auch kleinere, eher Start-up-ähnliche Unternehmen gibt. Oder das sind häufiger, ist das ja nicht, ist das sozusagen eine Mischung aus bürgerschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichem Interesse, dass ich sage, ich brenne für dieses Thema, aber vielleicht wäre es nicht schlecht, wenn ich auch ein bisschen Geld damit verdiene, weil am Ende muss irgendjemand auch die Miete zahlen. Das heißt, diese wirtschaftliche Nutzung ist auch sinnvoll. Es kommen eben auch relativ viele spannende Sachen dabei raus, wenn Leute sowas entwickeln.
Ihr seht, dass die wirtschaftliche Nutzbarkeit quasi ein Anreiz ist, dass sich Leute damit diesen Daten beschäftigen, was sie vielleicht mehr tun, wenn sie damit auch Geld verdienen können.
Ich glaube, dass es ja auch im Sinne des Staates ist, dass man gewisse Dienste einfach nicht verhindert zumindest. Also wenn irgendjemand eine Landkarte davon erstellen will, wo gerade giftiges Zeug austritt und das irgendwie als App im iTunes Store für 99 Cent vertickern will, warum sollte der Staat ihn daran irgendwie aktiv hindern? Das ist ja nun etwas, was im Interesse von uns allen ist.
Ich finde es schminkend nur halt, dass erstmal die Daten da sind, was dann die Leute damit machen. Es gibt ja auch von irgendwie Umweltämtern solche Karten, wo schonmal grob Schadar- stoffbelastungen aufgeführt werden, aber da ist dann wirklich eben die Frage, was dürfen andere Leute mit diesen Daten anfangen? Also wie weit kann ich mich darauf berufen, sie selber verwenden, um halt nochmal da zu legen? Das und das ist jetzt hier faul. Aber ein schönes Modell, was sozusagen diesen wirtschaftlichen Nutzen durch freie Daten, also der Staat kann sie nicht verkaufen, der Staat darf auch nichts verkaufen. Der Staat darf kein Profan machen, eigentlich. Interessanterweise machen Gemeinden gerne Geld irgendwie mit Straßen- und Verkehrsdaten. Aber bevor wir das nochmal aussehen, würde ich gern wissen, du hast das schon gesagt, Wetterdaten, die Frage muss ich natürlich stellen, verhalten sich in den USA ganz anders als in Deutschland.
Genau, also Wetterdaten sind so ein klassisches Beispiel. Die wurden in den USA von vornherein immer freigegeben.
Und das heißt, jeder kann alles damit machen, kann sie nochmal verkaufen, großere Schriftart draus machen und sagen, wenn du das in größerer Schriftart sehen willst, dann kannst du mir 5 Euro geben.
Genau, kann seine eigene Karte machen, kann das in seinen GPS einbauen. Das spannende an solchen Datenservice ist, dass manchmal gar nicht so sehr jetzt direkt irgendwie, ich nehme diesen Datensatz, baue damit irgendwas, dann ist es das, sondern das hier auch oft einfach helfen, um andere Dinge besser zu machen. Und ich baue das in meinen GPS ein, um zu wahren, dass es stürmen oder sowas. Und das hat halt dazu geführt, dass jetzt in Amerika einfach ein viel, viel größerer Markt für Wetterdaten entstanden ist. Ich glaube, die Schätzung, die ich im Kopf habe, ist irgendwo zwischen drei bis fünf Mal so groß. Und das ist natürlich auch irgendwie auch wirtschaftlich interessant. Es gibt so eine Studie aus den USA, die haben halt irgendwie so grob mal überschlagen, was dabei passiert, dass der Staat momentan in England, ich glaube 300 Milliarden grob mit Datenverkauf im Jahr einnimmt. Und das ist aber realistisch, dass wenn sie das Zeug veröffentlichen, dass dann daraus relativ bald eine Industrie von 1, 2 Billionen wird und dass man dann daraus irgendwie im Prinzip mehr Steuern macht, als man sozusagen bekommt, wenn man die Daten vertickert.
Also nicht mit den Daten, mit den Wetterdaten, Entschuldigung.
Das sind halt oft so halb private Sachen und oft gibt es auch einfach das Problem, dass so eine Behörde dann gesagt bekommt, Jungs, ihr macht ungefähr das halbwegs sinnvoll, könnt ihr nicht sozusagen so und so viel Prozent eures Haushalts selber stellen. Und dann müssen die halt wirklich losgehen und Daten verkaufen. Also das ist bei den Geoleuten sehr stark der Fall und bei ganz vielen anderen, die eben primär darauf abgezieht sind, Daten zu erheben.
Mit den Wetterdaten könnte es also noch eine Weile dauern. Wie gesetzten Fall eure Forderungen wird durchgesetzt, müsste man dann sowas wieder zurücknehmen? Also müsste das dann quasi wieder, müssten die Wetterdaten wieder eingemeindet werden und nicht mehr verkauft? Oder wie sollte das dann laufen?
Ich finde schon, dass man die Daten einfach freigeben kann.
Also auch nachträglich bitte.
Also wie gesagt, die Daten sollen freigegeben werden, aber die Firmen, die auch immer was damit machen, die gehen dann pleite.
Die können das weiterhin machen. Das ist ja gerade der Unterschied, den es in den USA gibt. Da gibt es halt eine Volkswirtschaft, die mit freien Wetterdaten, die der Staat einfach so rausgibt, die jeder für alles benutzen darf.
Ich möchte aber andererseits jetzt irgendwie die Volkswirtschaft der USA nicht unbedingt als Vorbild nehmen, wenn ich verstehe, was ich meine.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, es gibt ja zwei Seiten von dieser Geschichte. Erstmal ist der Gag, du sagst, um irgendwelche blöden Analogien zu nehmen, du lässt irgendein Grundnahrungsmittel, du gibst die Eier raus und wenn ich dann einen Kuchen draus backe und dann verkauf, werde ich auch weiterhin Kuchen damit verkaufen. Letztlich. Also die Idee ist, wenn ich mit diesem Grundding was mache und das auf eine schlaue Art und Weise weiterverarbeite, einen echten Mehrwert generiere, werde ich immer Geld damit verdienen. Das heißt also, es ist nur die Frage, ob ich vorher in so einer Art Oligopol hatte, wo es einen ganz engen Markt gab und drei Firmen das untereinander ausgemacht haben. Aber ich glaube, die Freigabe der Daten an sich ist nicht unbedingt, heißt nicht, dass diese Firmen, die jetzt bestehen, deswegen pleite gehen würden.
Na gut, das können wir gerne mal ausprobieren. Dann haben wir jetzt hier den Stefan in der Leitung. Hallo Stefan.
Ja, hallo.
Du würdest auch gerne was von unserem Staat wissen. Was denn?
Genau. Ich denke, wir bräuchten offene Verkehrsdaten. Wir haben jetzt gerade aktuell die Ergebnisse der Stiftung WarnTest zum Thema Verspätung der Deutschen Bahn und die haben den Umweg machen müssen, dass sie die jeweils für die aktuelle Istzeit veröffentlichten Daten der Deutschen Bahn über acht Monate gesammelt haben, um eine Aussage zu treffen, die die Deutsche Bahn nicht mehr öffentlich trifft, nämlich wie viel Prozent ihrer Züge sind verspätet. Und da ist das Interessante, da gibt es in anderen Städten und Ländern offene Datenschnittstellen, bei denen sich alle bedienen können. Wo dann zum Beispiel Privatpersonen ein Live-Tracking auf Basis von Karten, wie den Google Maps oder den Open Street Maps gebastelt haben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also es gibt ganz viele Gemeinden. Also ich glaube bei der Bahn, da weiß ich gar nicht mehr, ob die nicht mittlerweile zu weit weg von Deutschland sind, dass das sozusagen eine politische Entscheidung ist.
Sie sind noch nicht privatisiert, oder?
Sie sind noch nicht an der Börse, die Handheit eignen.
Sie sind privatrechtlich aber zu 100 Prozent in der Bundeshand. Insofern könnte der Eigentümerbund natürlich über den Aufsichtsrat eine solche Entscheidung treffen.
Gerne. Aber wahnsinnig interessant ist ja auch die Frage, was passiert mit Stadthaten. Also es gibt natürlich ganz viele spannende Sachen, die man machen kann mit den Daten der BVG meinetwegen.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Und nun ist es so, dass es dort auch im Prinzip die notwendigen Schnittstellen gibt, aber die werden halt dann eher vertickert an Google, als dass man sie wirklich frei für jeden verfügbar macht. Obwohl es dann natürlich auch wieder möglich wäre, damit interessante Dinge aufzubauen. Also es gibt ja einen Kumpel von mir, der hat eine Seite gebaut, mapnificent.de, da kann man zum Beispiel einfach eingeben, ich bin hier, zeig mir alle Orte an, wo ich innerhalb von 15 Minuten hinkomme. Und der streitet sich jetzt seit Monaten mit der BVG darüber, ob er überhaupt die Daten, die er von der Webseite runtergeladen hat, die er sich da zusammen gesammelt hat, überhaupt ob er die verwenden darf, die er von ihm vorher hätte.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da gab es doch so einen Fall, dass einer so eine iPhone App geschrieben hat, die eben den Fahrplaninterface von A nach B von der Webseite sozusagen benutzt. Und dann von der BVG erst mal so fett abgemahnt wurde, auch mit solchen Begründungen wie ja und dann können wir ja nicht garantieren, dass das wirklich die richtige Verbindung und so die Gerechtigkeit ist. Aber ich meine letztlich, nachdem das einen kleinen Skandal erzeugt hat, das war jetzt auch so zwei Jahre her etwa, hat die BVG das dann doch toleriert.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, der Typ hat dann irgendwann gesagt so, ach wisst ihr was BVG, dann rutscht man auf den Buckel runter und hat dann mit dem VBB, also dem Verkehrsverein Berlin Brandenburg ein Abkommen gesprochen, der natürlich genau dieselben Daten zur Verfügung hat, weil die ja zusammenarbeiten auch mit der Berliner U-Bahn. Und jetzt läuft diese App über die Daten vom VBB.
Nee, Öffi ist ja nur, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, eine reine Android-Anwendung. Also es war keine iPhone-Anwendung, insofern kann das nicht gewesen sein. Aber im Prinzip ist tatsächlich, dieses Beispiel zeigt sehr schön unsere Föderalismus, Städte und Gemeinden und so weiter. Konstellation, die wir hier in Deutschland haben. Nämlich, dass du nicht von ganz nach oben relativ leicht sagen kannst, so macht mal schön und das geht dann so hübsch, wasserfallartig bis in die untersten Ebenen. Sondern du hast allein in Berlin eine Vielteiligkeit von BVG und der Deutsche Bahntochter S-Bahn Berlin und so weiter. Dann hast du das wieder integriert eben in diesen Verkehrsverbund Berlin Brandenburg. Das heißt, du musst dich mit wahnsinnig vielen Leuten rumschlagen, bis du irgendwann vielleicht einen Minimalkonsens hast.
Müsstest du eigentlich nicht, weil was die alle verbindet ist, dass sie für den öffentlichen Nahverkehr Zuschüsse vom Senat bekommen. Und der Senat müsste schlicht und ergreifend nur in seine Verkehrsverträge, die er natürlich dann immer für längere Zeiten aushandelt. Diese Forderungen mit einbauen. Die Politik könnte das sehr wohl entscheiden. Schwierig ist natürlich an der Stelle, die Verträge werden in der Regel über 10 Jahre abgeschlossen. Was man dann während des laufenden Vertrags noch nachverhandelt, da würden die Unternehmen natürlich sofort wieder sagen, extra Geld bitte. Aber prinzipiell ist im Nahverkehr, hat die Politik absolut das Primat drauf. Wo es ein bisschen schwierig sein könnte, ist die Deutsche Bahn im Fernverkehr, die sagen würde, nee, wir sind ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen und müssen unsere Daten vor der Konkurrenz schützen und so was. Aber auch da würde ich behaupten, die Netzgesellschaft der Deutschen Bahn, die soll ja laut Grundgesetz immer mehrheitlich staatlich sein. Und wenn das der Bund wollte, könnte er das einfach festlegen, dass alle Daten der Netzgesellschaft, die ja letztendlich den Fahrplan überwacht, öffentlich sein müssen. Und ich finde das halt ein sehr einfach anschaulicheres Beispiel, als jetzt zum Beispiel bei den Wasserverträgen, weil da ist der Nutzen für jeden Einzelnen von uns leichter visualisierbar. Und da ist an den Beispielen, die es aus London und Helsinki und Tschechien gibt, auch zu erkennen, was...
Kannst du uns kurz erklären, was für Beispiele es da gibt?
Ja, also in London und Helsinki ist jeweils der öffentliche Nahverkehr auf einer Google Map dargestellt. Du kannst jeweils sehen, wo sich die einzelnen Fahrzeuge gerade lang bewegen. Ich kann das gerne gleich mal ins Blog reinschreiben, die Links.
In der Schweiz gibt es das auch.
Es gibt es mittlerweile auch in München. Man muss auch mal Deutschland...
Nein, ihr seid ja daher aus Süddeutschland.
Und es gibt auch eine Simulation von Berlin. Aber es ist leider eine Simulation.
Eine Echtzeit-Simulation.
Das sind keine Echtzeit-Daten, sondern die Fahrplan-Daten.
Ich möchte kurz sagen, das gibt jetzt gerade so ein ganz spannendes Punkt, wo so eine Grenze anscheinend für Open Access ist. Also die Bahn ist jetzt noch in staatlicher Hand. Der Nahverkehr, da könnte man das immer über Druckmittel redigen. Jetzt ist aber in der Tat so, es gibt ja Bereiche, wo öffentliche Infrastruktur privat versorgt wird. Ist OpenData, also geht ihr so weit, dass ihr sagt, auch da wollen wir dann sozusagen eigentlich die Daten haben? Also was wäre da vorspielbar? Letzte Mal in der Telekom zum Beispiel. Ist privatwirtschaftlich, aber Fernmelde, Telefonie, Internetanschluss ist jetzt ein öffentliches Bedürfnis? Oder, keine Ahnung, was gibt es noch?
Ich glaube, man muss schon ein bisschen sagen, ich glaube, dass man jetzt Unternehmen zwingt, dass sie ihre gesamten Datenbasen freigeben, dann glaube ich nicht so richtig. Ich glaube, dass es für viele Unternehmen Sinn machen würde, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es eine sinnvolle politische Forderung ist.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt diesen hübschen Begriff, darauf hast du auch angespielt, der sogenannten Daseinsfürsorge, wo ja auch sowas zählt wie, jeder muss einen Zugang zum Internet haben oder so. Aber das ist, glaube ich, das führt relativ weit. Ich würde da erstmal wirklich sagen, fangen wir bei den essenziellen Teilen an, wo du auch im Prinzip halt, wo du keine Konkurrenzverhältnisse hast. Bei den ganzen Telekom Sachen, da hast du natürlich prinzipiell Konkurrenz, zumindest im nicht ländlichen Raum. Insofern würde ich da schon erstmal eine Grenze ziehen, weil es gibt eben andere Bereiche, wo du eben mit diesen Zweigleisigen einerseits öffentlich Druck machen, auf das Thema aufmerksam machen, Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, auf der anderen Seite aber auch mit den Leuten konkret sprechen. Also es ist eben auch so eine Erfahrung des konkreten, ja letztlich Lobbings, wo man sieht, okay, es gibt da Leute, die sind da für das Thema, mit denen kannst du sprechen und die machen auch innerhalb ihrer Verwaltungen. Machen die auf das Ding aufmerksam? Und die Leute in den Verwaltungen bekommen eben auch was davon mit. Allmählich.
Und ich würde noch hinzufügen, bei so was in der Telefongesellschaft habe ich zum einen erstmal die Frage, was nützen mir diese offenen Daten jetzt für sozusagen meine politische Weiterbildung? Das ist ja das Interessante dann, OpenData, dass ich irgendwas damit politisch auch anfangen kann. Und auf der anderen Seite, als Kunde irgendeines Telekonektionsnutzern nehmen, habe ich natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch schon das Interesse, dass wenn Daten offengelegt werden, die nicht im Umkehrschluss Rückschlüsse ermöglichen, die dann datenschutzrechtlich problematisch sind.
Also mir geht es jetzt um die letzte Meile. Also sagen, das ist ja so, dass der Anschluss, der letztendlich in deinem Haus gelegt wird, immer noch von der Telekom gelegt wird, in den allermeisten Fällen. Und die Telekom behauptet immer, ja das geht nicht schneller und es ist so und so teuer und überhaupt ist das alles ganz kompliziert. Und da wäre es sozusagen schon mal sehr interessant zu wissen, ob das alles stimmt. Das könnte man natürlich bei OpenData überprüfen. Ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz bei dem Telekommunikationsbereich bleiben. Was mir da noch eingefallen ist, ist nämlich die Versteigerung von Frequenzen. Der letzte große Aufreger war ja bei UNTS-Frequenzen. Wie ist es mit solchen Geschichten? Sollen die dann öffentlich sein? Also sagen, wer hat da wie viel was geboten oder fällt das auch schon? Und der sagt, naja, da lassen wir erstmal die Finger von, weil zu heikel.
Wer hat was geboten?
Also sozusagen die einzelnen Bieter oder Bieterkonsortien für die Frequenzbereiche.
Es gibt also die UNTS-Frequenz, wo der Versteiger, das ist eine öffentliche Ressource, die gehört quasi uns allen, wird halt nur vom Staat verwaltet. Der Versteiger, das ist wiederum eine Firma. Wir wissen aber nicht genau, wer da Geld wann an wen und überhaupt. Könnte man aber auch sagen, das ist Betriebsgeheimnis.
Aber das Bieten ist ja kein staatliches Handeln. OpenData geht um Daten des Staates öffentlich legen.
Ich würde es auch fast eher da abschneiden, wo der Vertrag dann gemacht wurde.
Also, dass der Vertrag dann öffentlich ist. Okay, sagen wir aber nicht, dass der Beat vorhanden ist. Aber die Öffentlichkeit darf dann schon wissen, für wie viel Geld die öffentliche Ressource UMTS-Frequenzen versteigert wurde. Okay, Stefan, dir vielen Dank erstmal. Und ich hoffe, das mit den Zügen, das finde ich echt eine gute Idee. Das sollten wir mal machen. Bis dahin, tschüss! So der Frick fängt an. Chaos Radio ist heute, das hört man daran, dass manche Dinge durcheinander laufen. Zum Beispiel wäre das eigentlich nicht mehr geplant gewesen, weil das eigentlich nur am Anfang der Sendung funktioniert. Aber egal, zu Gast sind heute Wetterfrosch vom Chaos Computer Club und er hat zwei OpenData Aktivisten mitgebracht, nämlich Michael und Friedrich, den Nachnamen ich mir leider nicht mehr erkannt. Aber am Ende der Sendung, sag ich es noch mal hochoffiziell, ist ja auch alles OpenData, wo kann man es eigentlich nachschlagen? Wo findet man euch eigentlich im Netz?
Ich bin Poodle, das gibt es mit poodle.org und mit AddPoodle und solchen Varianten.
Okay.
Mich findet man unter gelegentlich, nein, also unter data-mining auch bei Twitter zum Beispiel. Und ansonsten findet man uns sozusagen als Organisation, als OpenData-Network.
Okay, weil jetzt gerade die Stunde ist, also Halbzeit, könnt ihr noch mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen in drei Sätzen. Was ist OpenData und warum gibt es dafür Aktivisten?
OpenData ist die Forderung, Daten des Staates vornehmlich, aber auch aus anderen Bereichen, wo sie öffentlich finanziert sind, frei zu geben, rechtlich frei zu geben und technisch frei zu geben, um damit eine Innovation sowohl in Transparenz, in Staat, in Politik, wie auch in Wirtschaft zu fördern.
Also prinzipiell heißt das, also ich meine, es gibt diese hübsche Formel von Warholland, die lautet öffentliche Daten nutzen, private Daten schützen. Und grundsätzlich geht es darum, jeder soll, ohne zum Beispiel sich irgendwo anmelden zu müssen, auf Daten zugreifen können, in einem Format, wo er vorher nicht irgendwie ein spezielles Programm für braucht und er muss nichts dafür bezahlen und er kann diese Daten weiterverwenden und er kann sie auch wieder verfügbar machen. Das ist so die Grundidee an diesen offenen Daten.
Jetzt hängt an euch beiden der schöne Titel Aktivisten und ihr habt doch schon erzählt, dass ihr Lobbyarbeit macht. Wie muss man sich das denn vorstellen? Also ich meine, okay, ihr habt sozusagen wahrscheinlich einen Verein, wo lauter Leute, die derselben Ansicht sind wie ihr, sich sozusagen aktiv beteiligen. Ja bestimmt auch der Webseite, wo man das nachlesen kann. Aber es geht ja letztlich darum, diese Thematik zu Leuten zu tragen, die keine Ahnung davon haben. Wie kann man sich das so ganz konkret, könnt ihr mal irgendwie, ich kann mir das immer nicht vorstellen. Wie sieht Lobbyarbeit eigentlich aus für so ein schwieriges, abstraktes Thema? Wo die Leute ja wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht wissen, dass es das gibt.
Also einerseits geht es natürlich um klassische Medienarbeit. Aber es geht darum, dass du Ansprechpartner bist für Journalisten, die was fragen, dass du Pressemitteilungen rausgibst, dass du Veranstaltungen machst oder mit auf Veranstaltungen bist, die sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigen. Das ist der eine Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt ist tatsächlich, sich mit Leuten zusammenzusetzen, die entweder auf dich zukommen oder dass du auf Leute zugehst.
Wie passt das? Wie kommt man an die ran?
Es gibt nichts Gutes, als man tut es. Ein Beispiel zum Beispiel wäre München. Da gab es jemanden in der IT-Strategie der Stadt, der hat sich gesagt, okay, wir müssen irgendwie mal über Offenheit nachdenken, hat einen Munich Open Government Day organisiert. Und dann haben wir uns eben mit dem zusammengesetzt und eben geguckt, was kann man machen, was für Daten gibt es in München, die interessant wären, wie kann man die rausgeben, wie kann man eventuell dann auch gleich einen Wettbewerb veranstalten, in dem Leute dann aufgefordert und eingeladen werden, eigene Nutzung dieser Daten vorzulegen und sozusagen wirklich eine Unterhaltung zwischen der Stadt und den Bürgern irgendwie zu fördern.
Jetzt hat er aber da sozusagen, ich nenne es jetzt mal nur der verdeutlichen halbe, der Mann von der anderen Seite, die grundlegend die Idee. Jetzt können wir nicht alle wie Inception irgendwie in den Köpfen der Politiker ran, diese Idee einpflanzen und sagen, wie kommt ihr denn auf diese Seite, dass ihr sagt so, komm mal her, wir müssen mal reden.
Nein, man braucht jetzt schon die Leute, die irgendwie gewillt sind und die auch auch Lust haben, was zu machen. Also ich glaube, es gibt in jeder Verwaltung irgendwie so ein paar Leute, die sind einfach begeistert für die Dinge und mit denen dann zusammenzuarbeiten, mit denen zusammen zu demonstrieren, okay, da lässt sich was Cooles machen. Das kann man einfach machen, das kostet auch nicht irgendwie für die Welt und das kann man irgendwie in einer relativ relativ unbürokratischen Manier abwickeln. Das ist, glaube ich, mit das Beste, was man machen kann und das Gleiche versuchen wir auch gerade zusammen mit der Berliner Senatsverwaltung zu machen. Da wird es jetzt am 18. Mai zum ersten Mal ein öffentliches Event geben, wo eben über OpenData geredet werden, wo Leute von der Politik, von der Verwaltung und von anderen, ja von Zivilgesellschaft zusammenkommen und eben diese Frage für Berlin diskutieren.
Jetzt seid ihr beiden also OpenData Aktivisten. Ich werde noch was von, wie gesagt, Open Knowledge Foundation, da gibt es irgendwas. Also wenn ich jetzt diese Stunde schon gehört habe, denke ich so, geile Idee, da will ich mitmachen. Was gibt es denn für Organisationen? Also wer ist das da noch, der sich darum kümmert?
Es gibt eine ganze große Zahl von Organisationen, die sich darum kümmern. Also das Open Data Network ist glaube ich so der zentrale Sammelpunkt für Leute in Deutschland, die sich dafür interessieren. Da gibt es die Seite eben opendatanetwork.org und eine Mailing-Liste, auf die man sich anmelden kann, wo man dann so grob mitbekommen, was läuft. Die Open Knowledge Foundation ist eine Organisation, die zuerst in England gegründet wurde und die eben ganz speziell sich mit Einzelprojekten befasst. Also viel Datenkatalogen, das kann man vielleicht nur kurz nachher erklären, und mit Finanztransparenzprojekten, aber auch mit freiem Wissen allgemeiner als zum Beispiel Literatur, die aus dem Urheberrecht rausgefallen ist, irgendwie ordentlich aufzufangen, wissenschaftliche Daten irgendwie vernünftig zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Also man kann also sagen, dass die Open-Out-Fundation sich ein bisschen mehr auch um die, letztlich die Infrastruktur kümmert, was offenes Wissen angeht.
Wie sich das besitzt, ist es ja so, diese offene Datenidee, da gibt es sozusagen Gegner, die aber fast schon klassischerweise dann sagen, wir haben was zu verbergen, wir sind dagegen irgendwie, weil uns das schadet. Aber generell scheint das eine Idee zu sein, die irgendwie wohl gelitten ist, aber die deshalb irgendwie nicht großzeitig umgesetzt wird, weil so, naja, wir haben eigentlich gerade ein wichtigeres zu tun. Also so kommt es gerade rüber.
Nee, nicht wichtigeres zu tun, sondern wir haben A, keine Ahnung, wo fangen wir jetzt an? Wie macht man das konkret? Was heißt das? Und B, auch irgendwie, manchmal glaube ich, ist es halt echt so ein bisschen, dass noch niemand sich auf der Bundesebene hingestellt hat, in der Bundesregierung gesagt hat, so Jungs, wir machen jetzt OpenData. Und dann sitzen die ganzen Leute in der Verwaltung und sagen, habe ich jetzt eigentlich Rückendeckung, wenn ich anfangen will, anstatt dass ich auf Informationsfreiheitsanfragen mit PDF-Dokumenten antworte, dass ich auf sie mit Excel-Dateien antworte. Darf ich das?
Ja, also da ist tatsächlich dieser Punkt mit dem nötigen Druck oder sozusagen dieser Rückendeckung, wenn du dir anguckst, die Beispiele in den USA oder auch in Großbritannien, wo es in beiden Fällen, also erst in den USA, Data.gov und dann später in Großbritannien, Data.gov UK gab, die einfach sozusagen genau andersrum gesagt haben, alles muss prinzipiell erst mal veröffentlicht werden, alle Verwaltungsdaten, also alle Regierungsdaten, die wir haben.
Woher kommt da diese Idee? Ist das gesellschaftlich verankert oder?
Es gibt, glaube ich, zwei unterrichtliche Ursprünge. Bei den Amerikanern, da war es Präsident Obama, der halt einfach ins Amt gekommen ist und der sich super kompetente Berater geholt hat. Und die haben halt gesagt, wir machen jetzt Open Government. Das heißt, wir machen einen transparenteren Staat. Wir machen einen Staat, der zur Beteiligung einlädt und einen Staat, der zur Kooperation einlädt. Und auf dieser Basis haben sie dann eben gesagt, das erste, was wir machen, ist, dass wir wirklich mal sammeln, was für Informationen gibt es alles, dass wir Leute einladen, eben wirklich Apps zu entwickeln, die dann diese Informationen nutzen, die da irgendwie Dinge bauen, die erstens irgendwie unser Staatswesen transparenter machen und zweitens auch im Alltag einfach nützig sind. Und haben sie mit großem Erfolg gemacht. Also zum Beispiel Washington hat unheimlich geniale Apps von wann kommt zunächst mal die Müllabfuhr bis hin zu in wieviel Minuten fährt eigentlich dort und dort der nächste Bus. Und gleichzeitig haben sie sich dann halt wirklich sich daran gekümmert, dass die ganzen Ministerien ihre Daten freigeben. Da gibt es bis heute so eine öffentliche Hitliste, wer hat am meisten veröffentlicht, wer hat den beliebtesten Kram veröffentlicht und sowas.
Wenn es nicht funktioniert, mach einen Videospieler raus. Eigentlich ein cooler Plan.
Ich glaube der zweite Punkt, wo du gerade noch angesetzt hast, ist eigentlich, wie es dann in Großbritannien gelaufen ist. Das ist letztlich einer der sozusagen Internet Erfinder Tim Berners-Dee, der tatsächlich gefragt wurde, während er um den Wahlkampf rum, was kann ich denn machen? Von David Cameron und ihm gesagt wurde, gibt die Daten frei, mach das. Und das interessante daran ist, dass letztlich die britische Regierung nach der Wahl, die nur gewählte, das tatsächlich umgesetzt hat. Also dieser Punkt, dass die das relativ umfassend oder sehr umfassend umgesetzt hat, hat einige Leute auch ein bisschen erstaunt. Aber es ist eben dieses tatsächlich dieses von oberster Stelle und in diesem Fall wirklich top down das zu machen, sorgt zumindest erstmal für eine Art Grundklima, das in eine andere Richtung geht, also eine sehr positive Landwirtschaft.
Wir erfahren heute in dieser Sendung wundersame Dinge, Wahlversprechen, die eingehalten werden.
Ich kann es auch konzentrieren. England, ja.
Also ganz richtig schlimm ist es nicht, die Amis haben gerade das Programm übel eingeschnitten.
Ja, aber das waren die anderen. Nein, es gibt auch dazu, ähm, weil wir gerade, ich bin gerade so ein bisschen so mit, ähm, wie sagt man, ähm, Synapsenschwenks unterwegs. Es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt in Großbritannien eine Seite, wo man sehen kann, wo konkret jetzt gerade wegen der Sparpläne, wo was, ähm, eingespart wird und du ganz konkret auf einer Karte ansehen kannst. Hier und da sind bei jedem Verein so viel wird eingespart, da und das. Und du kannst da auch wieder über die Karte sehen, dann reinklicken und dich immer tiefer reinklicken und sehen, wo vor Ort sozusagen was denn jetzt gekürzt wird. Das ist sozusagen auch eine Variante, wo man transparent macht, was passiert.
Da muss man aber ganz klar auch dazu sagen, in England hat das eine ideologische Komponente. Das heißt, die haben gerade dieses neue Programm einer Big Society und Big Society heißt sozusagen ein bisschen auch Small Government. Und da gibt es halt zum einen den Gedanken, wir geben die ganzen Finanzdaten raus, weil wir dann irgendwie besser rechtfertigen können, wenn wir kürzen. Und zum anderen gibt es halt auch den Aspekt, dass man sagt, okay, wir ermöglichen dadurch, dass wir sozusagen unser Handeln transparent machen, dass Bürger mehr davon übernehmen können und dass wir dadurch weniger staatliche Funktionen zur Verfügung stellen können. Das ist was, womit ich mich persönlich nicht verbinden möchte. Aber das ist sozusagen Teil der Argumentation dort.
So funktioniert es also anderswo bei uns. Müssen wir dann noch ein bisschen arbeiten, anscheinend. Ich möchte aber das noch mal ganz genau fragen. Es gibt bei uns keine Gegner. Es gibt nicht nicht nicht so. Also jetzt vielleicht. Also wie gesagt, vielleicht einzelne Personen, aber es gibt.
Es ist eigentlich ein Sonnenschein Thema.
Es gibt sozusagen eine Verwaltungskultur und auch eine Politikkultur, die sozusagen obergringlich staatlich ausgerichtet ist. Es gibt insofern keine Gegner, aber es gibt viele Leute, die nicht in the not amused sind.
Okay, aber das meine ich zu sagen. Es geht nur darum, sozusagen die alte Struktur aufzubrechen, um das zu machen. Aber es gibt nicht sozusagen jemanden, der grundsätzlich sagt, das ist das schlimmste Kritik, die ihr habt, so nee, das haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht so gemacht.
Naja, sagen wir mal, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, wie weit das tatsächlich sozusagen passiver und aktiver Gegner schafft, wie weit die da so besteht. Also ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen eine Alters- und Einstellungsfrage, dass ich mir vorstellen kann oder mein Eindruck auch ist, dass eine ganze Menge Leute, sagen wir über 50, da tatsächlich ganz und gar nicht im Use sind, weil sie finden, dass Leute da nicht drin rumzufuhrwerken haben, sondern dass es primäre Staatsaufgabe ist zu funktionieren und dass der Staat macht uns Wut und so weiter. Wir haben das jetzt sehr grob zusammengefasst, aber es ist auch andersherum, es ist eben in Verwaltungen, die natürlich auch so ein bisschen so einen Grund oder allen umfassenden Versorgungsanspruch haben. Das heißt, sie wollen, wenn sie an Daten stark gearbeitet haben, ist die Neigung eher dazu, noch eine hübsche Anwendung dazu entwickeln und nicht zu sagen, es ist ein Erfolg, wenn ich die Daten zur Verfügung gestellt habe und jemand anderes ganz tolle Daten Anwendungen daraus entwickelt hat.
Das ist ja auch gerne mal stolz, wie man in England gesehen hat, oder Amerika sagt so, wenn sie sich dran messen, welche öffentlichen Daten am meisten abgerufen werden, also die präsentieren ja auch mal gern, wenn sie jetzt selbst was durchgezogen haben. Aber das ist halt schon die Frage, das Argument, das am häufigsten dagegen spricht oder angeführt sind, da zusätzliche Kosten, noch mehr Verwaltungskosten, jetzt müssen wir das alles auch noch irgendwie aufbereiten, online stellen, wo man unsererseits mit relativ geringen Ansprüchen rangeht und sagt, erstmal so wie es da ist, nicht groß aufbereitet, den Rest kann man ja immer noch...
Jetzt haben wir vorhin schon ein Nebenthema gehabt, was da mit zusammenhängt, aber jetzt nicht ganz Thema ist. Das war Open Government, also eine transparent zu kontrollierende Regierung, wo Open Data eine Grundlage sein kann oder ist. Jetzt gibt es auch noch den Begriff von Open Access und da haben wir den Jakob am Telefon und der hat dazu eine Frage. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das hier reinpasst, aber Jakob kann sie erst mal stellen. Hallo Jakob.
Ja, die Frage ist im Grunde, wie es damit aussieht mit Open Access. Also das passt ja meiner Meinung nach, gehört es ja eben dazu, zu den deutlich finanzierten Projekten.
Erklären, was Open Access ist, die Herren hier im Studio?
Ich meine, die Grundidee dabei ist, dass du sagst, Open Access ist letztlich wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse, vor allem auch die dahinter liegenden wissenschaftlichen Daten, offen zugänglich zu machen. Weil der Wissenschaftsbetrieb funktioniert ja normalerweise bei diesen Sachen genau andersrum. Ich mache eine Forschungsarbeit, ich reiche die ein, die wird dann von anderen Wissenschaftlern meist anonym bewertet. Das geht ungefähr zwei Jahre lang, dann erscheint das irgendwann in einem Fachmagazin, für das man entweder als Papierding bezahlen muss oder für das Online-Abo bezahlen muss. Und irgendwann ist das Ding dann erschienen. Dann hast du da Einsicht rein und dann können die Leute erst auch auf diese Ergebnisse, meistens in kleiner Tabellenform oder so, auch die Daten zugreifen. Die Gegenidee ist eben, dass man das kostenlos, vor allem online, zugänglich macht. Das ist die Grund-Open Access-Idee und die hat für meine Begriffe auch eine ganze Reihe von Vorteilen.
Also ich glaube, das grundsätzliche Problem ist sozusagen diese Publikationsfrage. Wo kann ich veröffentlichen, damit es mir ausreichend Reputationen gibt, damit ich im wissenschaftlichen Betrieb weiterkomme? Und diese Frage wird halt momentan über Institutionen beantwortet, also große Verlage, die diese Publikationen bereitstellen.
Beziehungsweise diese Zitationsindizes und solche Sachen, die sich eben aus vor allem besonders reputierlichen Fachmagazinen speisen. Das heißt, wenn du von dem tollsten Fachmagazin zitiert wirst, dann hast du einen höheren, wie heißt das, Citation Impact oder so, als wenn du das vielleicht bis jetzt, zumindest in dem System, online und kostenlos veröffentlicht hast.
Ich muss aber als Autor dafür sogar bezahlen und dann natürlich noch am meisten an der Stelle.
Das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen an der Open-Exist-Diskussion in Deutschland kratzt. Das ist jetzt pauschal und ich bin da nicht vollkommen drin, aber dass sie mittlerweile nur noch darüber diskutieren, wer wem wann wie viel zahlt und man gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenkt, wie man sozusagen wirklich aus diesem, aus der institutionell getragenen Reputationsfalle rauskommt.
Und dann macht so eine Redaktion wie die Nature ein Review, wo es jetzt auch nicht so den transparentesten Eindruck macht, wonach sie sozusagen das vergeben. Und es gibt ja auch schon viele Konzepte und Experimente für, wie so ein offener, transparenter Review funktionieren kann. Also ich meine, das größte Experiment heißt ja wohl Wikipedia.
Aber jetzt glaube ich, ganz viel durcheinander. Die grundlegenden Ideen ist, an der Uni wird wissenschaftlich gearbeitet, die Uni ist vom Staat bezahlt, also die Ergebnisse bitte so streuen, dass wir alles lesen können.
Genau oder zumindest, und das ist gerade zu albern, wenn man es laut ausspricht, aber dass ich zumindest als Wissenschaftler das Recht habe, meine eigenen Materialien danach noch mal weiter zu nutzen und irgendwie auf meinem Blog zu veröffentlichen.
Sagen wir mal so, man auch diese Grundidee der Online-Veröffentlichung, vor allem auch sozusagen der Art Online-Review, der vorher erfolgt. Das heißt, andere Leute können schon das Zwischenergebnis, bevor es letztlich publiziert ist, angucken, können da schon zum Beispiel auch das Ding diskutieren, sagen, das und das finde ich gut oder haben bereits einen Zugang dazu. Das ist, glaube ich, prinzipiell ziemlich schlau, weil es eben sozusagen den Zugang vieler zu viel Wissen fördert. Also auch den ganzen wissenschaftlichen Ablauf.
Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder schon der zweite Schritt. Oder wenn man es so machen würde wie beim OpenData, dass man sagt, wir nehmen erstmal was mehr kriegen können, wäre ja wahrscheinlich die Forderung, okay, irgendwie veröffentlicht, haltet euren berühmten Papers, ist uns egal, aber dann bitte stellt es auch öffentlich zur Verfügung.
Es gibt ja da auch zwei Ansätze. Das eine sozusagen sofort und ausschließlich, nur Open zu veröffentlichen oder parallel.
Was wäre denn ganz konkret eure Änderung sozusagen im Urheberrechts für eine Diplomarbeit? Also wie sollte diese behandelt werden können, vielleicht ausgedrückt in einer Creative Commons Lizenz?
Sie sollte nicht von Guttenberg zitiert werden?
Nein, also ich glaube, die Diplomarbeit ist gar nicht unser Problem. Das Problem ist halt irgendwie dieser Alltagstrott, in dem Wissenschaftler sind, die sich irgendwie ihre Sache erarbeiten wollen. Und ich glaube, es gibt noch ein zweites und etwas größeres Problem, was man vielleicht noch ansprechen kann. Das ist sozusagen die Frage von Informationen, die sozusagen ein Kernprodukt eines wissenschaftlichen Prozesses sind. Also zum Beispiel Informationen über das Genom oder Informationen über, meinetwegen sogar, synthetische Lebensformen, die wir mittlerweile schaffen. Und da die Frage, kann ich so etwas patentieren, was ja dann auch im Prinzip eine Verletzung der Idee von offenem Zugang ist? Kann ich ein neues Reißkorn, was ich irgendwo in Indien entdeckt habe, kann ich das patentieren und damit jedem anderen verbieten, das weiterzunutzen? Also das ist eine spannende Diskussion, die sich da letztendlich auch anschließt.
Jakob, sind damit deine Fragen geklärt erst mal?
Ja, ich hatte sogar mehr in die Richtung gedacht, dass auch so Rohdaten veröffentlicht werden direkt.
Also ich sag mal so, ich glaub die Rohdatenidee, das gehört auch dazu. Allerdings kannst du die natürlich nicht vor der zu sagen erst veröffentlichen, aber das gehört ganz klar zu den klassischen Open Access Forderungen, dass du sagst, die Daten sollen raus. Weil das ist ja die Idee, letztlich sozusagen die Überprüfbarkeit, die Weiterverwendung sozusagen auch zu gucken, ist da irgendwo eine Fälschung drin. Wir haben ja einiges gelernt über Fälschungen in letzter Zeit in der Wissenschaft.
Ich glaube, gerade diese Datenforderungen, die ist unheimlich wichtig, zum Beispiel auch weil es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit ist, sicherzustellen, dass viele gescheiterte Extrumente veröffentlicht werden.
Und ein weiterer Punkt ist auch sozusagen die sozusagen eine Art Naturschutz, nein, also Bestandsschutz. Das heißt nämlich, wenn einerseits irgendwie so ein Ding dann in einer Bibliothek vor sich hingammelt habe ich nichts dagegen, wenn ich eine übergeordnete große Online-Datenbank habe, die sozusagen auch öffentlich getragen wird, dann ist dafür gesorgt, dass diese Daten vielleicht auch noch 50 Jahre später zugänglich sind. Oder die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie von möglichst vielen Leuten in einem gemeinsamen Format verfügbar ist, ist damit deutlich höher.
So, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder? Alles klar. Viel Spaß noch. Ihr könnt auch weiterhin anrufen, wenn ihr OpenData habt oder haben wollt, und zwar unter dieser Nummer. 0331 70 97 110 Was ich ja gerne noch hören würde im Verlauf der Sendung, sind ein paar Erfolgsgeschichten. Also möglicherweise nicht aus Deutschland, aber möglicherweise aber auch doch. So Dinge, wo OpenData schon mal richtig gut geklappt hat, jetzt mal abgesehen von U-Bahn-Fahrplänen.
Also ich persönlich bin immer so ein bisschen begeisterungsfähig für die Dinge, die wirklich einem erklären, wie der Start funktioniert. Und da gibt es halt unheimlich viele spannende Sachen. Also eine Sache, die ich liebe, ist opencongress.org.com. Wo man einfach gucken kann, was macht der US-Congress gerade. Das gleiche gibt es auch in England, They work for you. Wo man genau gucken kann, was macht eigentlich mein MP gerade.
Und was steht da genau drin?
Da steht drin, dein MP ist 10% konservativer als normale MPs. Und hat diese und diese Position zu diesen und diesen Themen. So ein kleiner Katalog von 20 Themen und so was. Und es wurde halt erstellt im Prinzip durch Data Mining der Parlamentsreden, durch Data Mining auf die Abstimmungsergebnisse der Parlamentshäuser und so weiter und so fort.
Es gibt sozusagen eine relativ hübsche Anwendung, die auch sogar von einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender kommt, nämlich vom ZDF. Es gibt das Parlameter. Das ist auch eine relativ spannende Anwendung. Weil du kannst erst mal da dir angucken, also du kannst es aufschlüsseln nach Parlamentsfraktionen. Du kannst aber auch relativ weit das runterfiltern. Du kannst es bis hingehen, dass du siehst, ein einzelner Abgeordneter der FDP männlich mit überdurchschnittlich hohen Nebeneinkünften hat folgendermaßen abgestimmt oder sich enthalten. Du kannst es auf relativ viel runterbrechen und nochmal mit Teilsachen oder hat überdurchschnittlich geringe Nebeneinkünfte oder solche Geschichten.
Apropos runterbrechen. Das macht Spaß. Das Ganze kann man natürlich auch geografisch runterbrechen. Es ist irgendwie wahr, dass die interessantesten Entscheidungen auf lokaler, auf kommunaler Ebene gefällt werden. Da gibt es auch ganz spannende Projekte. Hier in Deutschland gibt es ein Projekt, das heißt Frankfurt Gestalten. Das sind ein paar Frankfurter, die sich hingesetzt haben. Frankfurt Main. Die sich hingesetzt haben, das Parlamentssystem der Stadt gescrept haben und jetzt auf eine Karte plotten, worüber der Stadtrat gerade verhandelt. Also die verhandeln gerade über eine Baustelle an der und der Straße oder über Dinge, die in dem und dem Viertel passieren. Das Gleiche gibt es zum Beispiel auch in England. Eine schöne Seite. OpenD Local. Die haben das dann zum Beispiel wieder verbunden mit wofür hat welches Council wie viel Geld ausgegeben. Auch da gibt es natürlich in England mehr Daten als bei uns. Aber auch wir haben die einzelnen Councils sich verhalten. Oder was ich auch schön finde, ist etwas wie Planning Alerts, wo man einfach eine E-Mail bekommt jedes Mal, wenn im Umkreis von 5, 10, 20, 50 cm in den eigenen Wohnort irgendwie ein Bauvorhaben aktuell wird.
Um mal nachzugucken, ob man das überhaupt will, oder?
Um einfach die Gelegenheit zu haben, sich politisch zu involvieren, bevor irgendwie die Abrissbirne kommt.
Jetzt haben wir, als wir uns vor der Zeit darüber unterhalten haben, Apropos Straßenbau, ging es auch irgendwie um so Dinge, wo man, auch in Großbritannien glaube ich, wo man irgendwie Schlaglöcher melden kann, oder sowas in der Richtung. Gehört das auch dazu?
Das ist so ein bisschen Randgebiet. Es gibt eine wunderschöne Seite FixMyStreet. Da gehe ich einfach drauf. Das gibt es auch in Deutschland in verschiedenen Varianten mittlerweile. Aber FixMyStreet ist sozusagen die ursprüngliche Idee. Ich gehe da drauf, wenn ich irgendwo ein Schlagloch sehe, wenn ich irgendwo Müll rumliegen sehe, wenn ich irgendwo sehe, dass eine Scheibe eingetreten ist oder sowas. Und kann einfach das registrieren. Und dann wird sozusagen in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt, hier guck mal, da ist ein Bericht. Und dann haben die die Behörden die Möglichkeit zu reagieren, zu sagen, okay, da haben wir jemand hingeschickt. Oder guck mal, da gibt es 20 Dinge, die sind gerade wichtiger. Dann machen wir die erstmal und dann kommt irgendwie das dran. Und das finde ich eine superschöne Sache. Das ist in dem Sinne nicht Government Data, sondern es ist eher irgendwie kollaboratives Sammeln. Man muss sich bewusst machen, dass Staaten von vornherein die größten Crowdsourcing-Organisationen sind, die wir jemals hatten. Es gibt zum Beispiel die 112. Wir hätten nicht die Möglichkeit, überall einen Feuerwehrmann hinzustellen. Aber dadurch, dass wir diesen Prozess Crowdsourcen, haben wir Feuervorsorge.
Ich mach kurz zurück, dieser FixMyStreet, aber der Teil nach der Meldung basiert doch schon auf OpenData. Also der funktioniert ja nur, wenn die Verwaltung.
Wenn der Staat transparent handelt. Genau. Oder wenn die Verwaltung. Es gibt in Deutschland ein Märkern Brandenburg, das ist ein ähnliches Projekt. Da kann man auch ganz schön gucken. Das ist auch ein Einblick in die Interessen und Stürfnisse der Bürger, die dort unterwegs sind.
Die Lebenswelten unter Umständen auch. Es sind halt wirklich die lokalste Ebene, an die du kommst. Da beschweren sich dann Leute darüber, dass Jugendliche immer ohne Helm mit Motorrädern auf irgendeiner Freifeliche rumfahren. Ihnen gefällt das nicht. Das reflektiert natürlich auch ein bisschen, wie es den Leuten da geht. Aber es ist natürlich auch einfach die klassischen Sachen. Da und dort gehen die Straßenlaternen nicht, da ist ein Schlagloch. Und du kannst dann tatsächlich sehen, wird bearbeitet oder kann gerade nicht bearbeitet werden. Und es ist dann auch grün markiert, wenn das bearbeitet ist. Und da ist eben so ein kurzer Eintrag von einem Sachbearbeiter, wenn es grün markiert ist, wurde ordnungsgemäß der Firma übergeben, die sich darum kümmert. Oder kann gerade nicht übergeben werden, weil wir erst ab April wetterbedingt Schlaglöcher auspülen.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Ist das einfach nur so eine Tabelle, wo ich irgendwie was reinschreibe? Oder ist das auch so eine schöne Karte?
Merkel Brandenburg hat durchaus eine Karte. Ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass das wahrscheinlich keine Webdesign Awards gewinnt. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch eine Software.
Eingabemaske ist letztlich das Wort dazu.
Okay, eine schicke Eingabemaske. Wir spielen jetzt noch ein Stück Creative Commons Musik. Vor allem Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Das hat der Michael mitgebracht. Das ist von Mild Tape. Bist du da einfach nur drüber gestolpert und hast gesehen, oh ja, könnte man mal oder gibt es da noch eine Geschichte zu?
Sagen wir mal, die Geschichte ist, dass ich eine gewisse Affinität zu Dub und Elektro-Sachen habe. Das ist aber der wesentliche Punkt dazu.
Okay, Extend of the Food. Gut, viel Spaß dabei und dann wie gesagt, nach dem FritzInfo geht's weiter.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu den Datenverkehrsmeldungen. Keine Sperrungen ohne Gesetz. Der Generalanwalt des Europäischen Gerichtshofes stellt klar, dass ohne eine gesetzliche Grundlage kein Gericht einen Internetprovider zur Sperrung einer Seite verpflichten darf. Wir empfehlen jegliche Gesetzesinitiative hierzu, etwa im Bereich des Urheber- oder Glücksspielrechts, weiträumig zu umwählen. Ägypten, das Kabinett, überarbeitet das eigene Kommunikationsrecht dahingehend, dass in einem Krisenfall die zuständigen Behörden künftig nicht mehr die Internet- und Telefonanbieter zur Abschaltung der Netze anweisen dürfen. Wir wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de fritz.de Und das Auge hört mit, man. Heute ist Chaosradio und zwar Nummer 167. Markus Richter ist hier am Start und hat drei Gäste gleich. Der eine ist der Typ, der sich gerade den Kopfhörer aufsetzt und jetzt so tut, als wäre er schon lange im Studio gewesen. Wetterfrau Schaloon, guten Abend.
Ein Abend.
Ja, wie gesagt, in der nächsten Sendung drücke ich das Mikrofon wie er selber. Er hat gesagt, er sei schon groß und könne das alleine. Ich kann nichts dafür. Außerdem ist da der Friedrich, ein Open Data Aktivist. Und dessen Mikro muss ich wieder rumhauen. Okay, so viele Runden Malmarte, die heute ausgegeben werden müssen, kann unmöglich irgendeinen Mensch trinken. Friedrich, herzlich willkommen. Und der Michael ist auch da auch ein Open Data Aktivist.
Ja, mein Mikro ist auch offen.
Open Data ist wie gesagt, Open Mic. Open Data sind die Daten, die der Staat sammelt mit unserem Geld. Und die wollen die Open Data Aktivisten öffentlich haben. Wir haben schon gerade darüber gesprochen, wie man das macht, dass der Staat das macht, was für Probleme es da gibt, was für gesetzliche Hürden, aber auch dafür Sprechungen, welche Themen man damit anfassen könnte, welche Sachen es anderswo gibt. All das könnt ihr euch nachhören, wenn ihr den Podcast, die Sendung hat, ungefähr eine Stunde später dann erscheint. Die Frage ist aber noch, Open Data gibt es doch bestimmt auch schon. Wir werden ja nicht ganz bei Null anfangen. Welche Daten werden schon veröffentlicht, die möglicherweise sinnfrei sind oder aus denen man möglicherweise mal was basteln könnte?
Also es gibt eine ganz wenige von Daten in Deutschland. Wenig. Im Prinzip gibt es hier keine Daten, die vom Staat freigegeben werden, die wirklich als Open Data lizenziert wurden. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel die Daten von der Bundesstatistik. Die liegen im Web und jeder kann sie nutzen, wenn er sie denn sozusagen die Quelle nennt. Es gibt zum Beispiel Sachen wie die Information der BaFin, wo recht viele interessante Sachen rumliegen.
Können wir kurz ein Beispiel noch sagen, also Bundesstatistik, was steht da drin?
Das ist eine riesengroße Sammlung von unterschiedlichen Sachen. Von der Bevölkerung pro Bundesland, Kinder pro Familie, wirklich diese ganzen Dinge, die man sich immer vorstellt. Import, Export, wie entwickeln sich unterschiedliche Güterklassen, bis hin zu wie entwickelt sich die Demografie. Wirklich diese ganzen Sachen. Das Problem mit den Sachen ist, dass im Prinzip alle interessanten Fragen, die man aus diesen Daten beantworten kann, beantworten die Statistiker normalerweise. Das heißt für uns als OpenData-Leute ist das eher als Füllmaterial interessant.
Das heißt aber zu sagen, das ist schon mal ein Bereich, wo das geklappt hat, wo das so gut geklappt hat, dass auch schon die Aufwertung der Daten, die Auswertung der Daten quasi geschehen ist.
Genau, also die werden von dem Bundesamt für Statistik und von den Landesämtern irgendwie bereitgestellt. Es gibt dort die Daten, es gibt diese ganz gute Regel, dass man sie benutzen darf. Das ist echt ein Paradebeispiel dafür, wie das in Deutschland aussehen kann.
Also das Statistikamt, da kann ich die Daten auch für alle anderen Zwecke, wenn ich da einmal rankomme, nutzen. Genau, das heißt es gibt leider wirklich nur diese effektiven Verwaltungskosten, dass ich da an die Daten rankomme. So eine Mitgliedschaft machen sie da ja irgendwie.
Es gibt so einen Webservice, da zahlt man im Prinzip dafür, dass man diesen Webservice nutzen darf, aber die Daten kann man zum Beispiel unter opendatalabs.org/desdatisins Web stellen.
Das wäre ja auch noch mal so eine interessante Frage, was ist denn so, zweitgleich sich eure Strategie zum einen irgendwie die Politik, den Staat dazu zu überreden, die Daten verfügbar zu machen und die andere Nummer halt einfach die Daten zu nehmen, die da sind. Und an der Stelle wäre es aber legal oder sozusagen kein Problem, wenn man sich da für einen Monat den Account holt, sich alle Daten holt und dann weitergibt. Das stinkt doch nach, habt ihr das schon gemacht?
Macht ihr das immer wieder?
Es gibt auch eine Möglichkeit, wenn man sagt, was sind denn diese offenen Daten? Wurde das jetzt bereits in Deutschland, in anderen Ländern gemacht? Es gibt hier auch ein Mitglied des Open Data Network, der da so einen ganz hübschen Showroom gemacht hat, der auch opendatashowroom.org heißt, wo du dir einfach so deutsche und internationale, europäische Daten angucken kannst und eben auch showroommäßig recht schön präsentiert.
Aber vielleicht nochmal weiter mit Daten.
Wo finde ich den? Wie finde ich den?
Das Ding heißt auch wirklich opendatashowroom.org. Da klickst du drauf und da findest du in verschiedenen Bereichen. Hübsche Daten oder Beispiele für hübsche Daten.
Jetzt haben wir hübsche Daten, wir haben auch schon Daten, die verwendet wurden. Gibt es auch Daten, die rumliegen, aus denen auch nichts gemacht wurde? Oder Daten, die es gibt und die auch ein bisschen Banane sind?
Es gibt unheimlich viel Zeug, was man findet, wo man immer nicht genau weiß, darf ich es jetzt nutzen, wie darf ich es nutzen, wann darf ich es nutzen. Ein riesen Ding ist das Portal U. Da sammeln alle Leute, die in Deutschland irgendwas mit Umwelt zu tun haben, Informationen. Umwelt ist insofern ganz interessant, weil unter der Schröder-Regierung verschiedene Gesetze erlassen wurden, die für Umwelt und auch für Verbraucher höhere Transparenzstandards vorsehen. Das heißt, da gibt es einfach bereits mehr Informationen und die sind auch mit der Technik ganz fit dabei, das ganze Zeug zu sammeln.
Oh, da hab ich auch noch so eine persönliche Neugierde, auch im Anschluss an die letzte Sendung und wo das ja gerade so aktuell ist. Es gab in der deutschen Geschichte der Kernkraft 3 oder 6.000 Störmeldungen. Letzte Sendung war ja auch schon das Thema ein bisschen, habt ihr euch damit mal beschäftigt, weil das ein heißes Eisen ist, weil jeder dieser Störfälle muss ja gemeldet werden an eine behördliche Stelle, wie verfügbar diese Daten sind?
Also sagen wir mal so, es gibt, wir hatten gerade zufälligerweise heute nochmal auf einer Mailingliste recht ausführlich eine Bestandsaufnahme über öffentliche Daten in Baden-Württemberg. Und es gibt da auch von den verschiedenen Umweltverwaltungen dort in Baden-Württemberg eine Übersicht. Du kannst dir das jetzt auch schon ganz nett angucken, du kannst da reinklicken und siehst verschiedene Messstellen im Umkreis von einem Atomkraftwerk, beispielsweise Philipsburg, und kannst es dir angucken auf einer Karte. Hier und da wird gemessen und diese Sachen, diese Daten kannst du auch dir richtig zusammensuchen und letztlich dir runterladen, auch als Excel-File oder sowas.
Auch als Archiv? Also weil es gibt so ein bundesweites Netz, aber die letzten zwei Monate, da frag ich mich dann auch immer so super.
Nee, das geht richtig. Ich hab mir das auch mal zum Spaß heute mal richtig durchgeklickt und ich konnte dafür beliebige Messpunkte bis 2009 oder so, jede erhobene dann eben in Millisievert und so weiter mir das angucken. Das kannst du einerseits einfach so als rohe Daten nehmen, du kannst es dir auch nochmal erläutert anschauen. Das sind allerdings Sachen, da ist so ein bisschen der Punkt, die sind nicht sozusagen ausdrücklich als OpenData gelabelt, sondern die sind aber offen zugänglich und du kannst sie dir runterladen.
Wir können ja noch ein bisschen weiter in die Zwieligzone gucken.
Also weil noch kurz soweit ich mich eingelesen hatte zu Radioaktivität, man ist zur Meldung verpflichtet an eine Behörde, wenn es kritisch ist, dann geht es sozusagen ans Ministerium. Aber in diesem ganzen Atomgesetz hatte ich keinen Passus wirklich gefunden, der, also klar, wenn es wirklich ein Ernstfall ist, dann muss die Öffentlichkeit informiert werden, aber der sozusagen einfach einen regulären Zugriff auf diese ganzen kleineren Zwischenfälle, wenn man das mal so milde formuliert, nicht irgendwie weiter regelt. Und ich meine, da wäre dann bestimmt wieder als nächstes der Punkt Betriebsgeheimnis oder so, was wir vorhin hatten. Also wir hatten Gegner gesucht, das kam noch im Chat der Hinweis, wenn wir Gegner suchen, dann sozusagen die Unternehmen, die mit dem Vertrag, mit dem Start in irgendeinem Vertragsverhältnis stehen, die werden sich natürlich immer dagegen sträuben, dass da irgendwelche Sachen vielleicht oder die genauen Beträge öffentlich gemacht werden. Das heißt, eigentlich muss man jetzt ja schon Gesetzesinitiativen ergreifen, die da so einen Umdenken in welche Richtung...
Genau, es gibt ja in Deutschland dieses Umweltinformationsgesetz. Insofern würde ich fast sagen, dass du gute Chancen hättest, an Stratungsdaten ranzukommen, sofern sie noch nicht öffentlich sind. Gleichzeitig gibt es eben Verbraucherinformationsgesetz und es gibt das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, womit man sozusagen beliebige Informationen anfragen kann. Es gibt jetzt von Greenpeace so den ganz sinnvollen Vorstoß, dass man diese drei Dinge in einem Ding zusammenfasst, weil einfach die Transparenzgesetze ziemlich intransparent sind. Man weiß einfach nicht, vielleicht klingt es ja eigentlich ganz wunderbar.
Drei Gesetze, die mir frei garantieren. In den USA läuft es ja von der Philosophie hier seit jeher ganz anders. Da gibt es ja den Grundsatz, dass alle Werke, die der Staat schafft, grundsätzlich unter Public Domain stehen. Ist so ein bisschen wie das, was wir am Anfang der Sendung auch kurz referenziert haben, das im deutschen Urheberrechtsgesetz ja steht. Dieses Urheberrechtsgesetz trifft nicht auf Werke, die der Staat schöpft. Was dann stattdessen greift, steht da wohl irgendwie nicht so ausfindig. An der Stelle in den USA ist es halt wohl irgendwo ziemlich prominent aufgehangen im Gesetzeswesen, dass alles, was der Staat macht, so frei ist, dass man nicht mal den Namen nennen braucht. Ich kann irgendwie als Autofirma dahergehen, mir ein Foto von der NASA vom Hubble Teleskop nehmen und sagen hier Star Galaxy, das neue Auto, und damit irgendwie Werbeplakate drucken und muss niemanden irgendwie was dafür geben und nicht mal sagen, dass ihr das Foto von der NASA habt. Und das gilt da irgendwie so grundsätzlich für alles. Und dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das wir in Deutschland bekommen hatten, ist ja immer so, du kannst fragen. Mehr sagt es ja im Kern auch erstmal nicht. So grundsätzlich muss es verfügbar sein. Dir muss ein Aufwand berechnet werden können, wenn es einen so als Gebühr, wenn es einen erfordert. Aber so recht irgendwie die Aktenordner eingescannt und online gepackt haben sie ja deswegen nicht.
Sagen wir mal, der Punkt ist ja sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, könnte man das auch in einer gewissen Weise als eine Art Opt-in und Opt-out nennen. Du hast das Recht, dass du diese Informationsfreiheitsanfrage stellen kannst. Und die Stelle auf der anderen Seite muss dir diese Information stellen. Aber es ist erstmal nicht definiert, die müssen von sich aus erstmal alles zur Verfügung stellen. Und du hast die Daten damit schon. Das ist ein bisschen das Grundding im Moment bei der Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland.
Da kann man gleich dann fragen, wenn man das Zeug ohnehin freigeben muss, warum stellt man das nicht auf irgendeine Webseite? Und zum anderen ist natürlich das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auch irgendwie leider so ein bisschen löchrig. Das heißt, es gibt viele Ausnahmen, es gibt sozusagen die Bedingungen, dass eben keine laufenden politischen Prozesse betroffen sein dürfen, keine Geschäftsgeheimnisse und natürlich Dinge, die wir auch beibehalten wollen. Also Sicherheit, öffentliche Sicherheit und Datenschutz.
Aber macht man da nicht dann der Argumentation Tür und Tor auf, ah ja, all die bösen Terroristen, können wir euch leider nicht sagen?
Ich glaube, ich hab noch ehrlich gesagt sehr sehr selten bisher Daten gefunden, bei denen man sinnvoll argumentieren konnte, dass die nun dem Terrorismus die Tür öffnen.
Na ja klar, die haben CDL nicht gezeigt. Nein, was ich meine zu sagen, ob das dann nicht als Feigenbettchen benutzt wird. Dass man sagt, ah na, das betrifft aber die Sicherheit. Oder wo ist CDL ein Punkt? Also wer darf das denn entscheiden, dass die Daten nicht...
Momentan passiert das halt in den Behörden. Und das ist so ein Prozess, den man in die Öffentlichkeitsherren muss, glaube ich.
Das ist aber schwierig, weil an irgendeiner Stelle musst du in einer Vertrauensbasis... Weil die Behörde kann ja schlecht sagen, du darfst jetzt diese Daten nicht sehen, weil... Weil mit der Begründung weißt du ja schon wieder...
Das Problem ist ein bisschen oder der Punkt, wie es jetzt läuft, ist, dass häufig tatsächlich bei Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen einfach sozusagen das ganze Ding nicht veröffentlicht wird in Einzelfällen, weil es heißt, darf nicht. Die andere Variante wäre ja, einzelne Passagen zu schwärzen und das dann zu veröffentlichen.
Gerade in PDF-Dokumenten sind damit ja viele positive Erfahrungen gemacht worden in letzter Zeit.
Ja, insgesamt ist es mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, dass das jetzt dann überarbeitet wird. Weil es ist, glaube ich, fünf Jahre ziemlich genau her, seitdem das in Kraft getreten ist. Und das muss jetzt überarbeitet werden. Insofern sind wir hier an einem ganz interessanten Punkt, wo man sagen kann, okay, wie wollen wir das in Zukunft haben?
Gleichzeitig gibt es wieder mal England. Ja, es gibt sozusagen einen super Prozess, den man machen kann, dass man die Anfrage, die man gestellt hat, ins Web stellt. Es gibt eine Seite www.whatdothenow.com und da wird dann einfach auch die Antwort veröffentlicht. Das heißt, wenn da keine Antwort erfolgt, dann ist das eben wenigstens öffentlich dokumentiert. Und wenn da bereits eine Antwort erfolgt ist, dann kann auch jemand anderes, der die gleiche Antwort will, da schneller dran kommen. Das ist so was, was es in Deutschland auch sehr weit geben wird.
Nämlich wann, wo, wie, was? Ah, das ist aber nicht sehr transparent.
Das klingt nicht von Seiten dem Staat aufgezogen.
Na schön, wer sind denn eigentlich so die nächsten Zukunftspläne? Was macht ihr morgen und was macht ihr in fünf Jahren?
Gerade, ich persönlich bastle am offenen Parlament.
Das heißt was?
Das ist der Bundestag und der Bundesrat und das Europäische Parlament. Unterlagen, mich interessiert dabei sozusagen, wie sieht die politische Agenda gerade wirklich aus, wenn man sie runterbricht auf Zahlen, womit setzen sie sich Tag für Tag auseinander, womit setzt sich welche Ausschüsse auseinander und so weiter und so fort.
Du schaust dir gerade diese grausamen Suchmasken und Interfaces von diesen ganzen EU-Dokumentsbibliotheken an.
Die haben die großartigsten Suchmasken. Ich wusste nicht, dass man so viele Formfelder auf eine einzige Webseite packen kann.
Was vielleicht in vor fünf Jahren passiert ist, gerade jetzt in Berlin ein bisschen dafür zu sorgen, dass mehr Daten rauskommen. Und das ist auch gerade diese Probleme, die es in den letzten zwei Jahren gab. Nämlich, diese Dinger sind urheberrechtlich oder auch wirtschaftsrechtlich geschützt, sich da in eine Richtung zu bewegen, dass da mehr rauskommt. Das ist, glaube ich, mehr so die kurzfristigere Agenda.
Und dann muss man sagen, gibt es mittlerweile auch beim Bundesministerium des Inneren eine Abteilung, die sich sozusagen mit Open Government auseinandersetzen soll. Und die sind gerade dabei, sozusagen eine Koalition der Willigen zu schmieden. Das sind sowohl Ministerien wie Bundesländer, die sich eben daran beteiligen wollen, Daten rauszugeben. Das heißt, da will man dann auch in einiger Zukunft einen Datenkatalog veröffentlichen und damit eben nachziehen. Das ist aber bisher noch ein wenig in den Kinderchulen, aber da sind Leute dran und die kümmern sich und die wollen.
Ich glaube, man kann auch sagen, die arbeiten daran sozusagen Schritt für Schritt auch irgendwie den Zugang zu diesen ganzen Daten zu bieten. Die haben, sagen wir mal, das Ganze malt auch relativ langsam. Ich glaube, ich spreche hier keine Geheimnisse aus, wenn das im Moment ein Ziel ist für so eine zentrale Dateneinstiegsseite, die vom Bund getragen wird oder in dem Fall vom Bundesinnenministerium, dass die 2013 in der ersten Form da sein soll. Also das ist jetzt nicht übermorgen.
Das Problem ist, die haben halt keine ganz klar formuliertes Mandat, sondern die könnten gut ein bisschen Rückendecken brauchen.
Was die Statistikseite machen kann, haben wir dann jetzt geklärt. Wie ist es eigentlich auf der User-Seite? Also ich meine, ihr setzt euch dafür ein, ihr seid jetzt zwei dort, ihr habt noch einen Verein, da gibt es noch ein paar. Kann, soll, darf die Bevölkerung, wir alle vom Neuartigen Rundfunkumfangsgerät, gerade da irgendwas dran machen und wenn ja was?
Ich glaube, da gibt es ganz viele Dinge, die man machen kann. Also natürlich jeder, der in der Lage ist, ein bisschen Code zu schreiben, sollte das tun und sollte dabei interessante Dinge zeigen und uns helfen zu verstehen oder uns alltäglich Probleme lösen damit.
Das war ganz nur ein Aspekt mit dem Codeschreiben. Also es geht nicht ausschließlich um die Hacker, sondern es geht einfach auch um Leute, die sich interessieren. Die können natürlich einerseits sagen, ja, Open Data Networks zum Beispiel, ja, würde ich gerne mitmachen. Es ist ein Aspekt, aber auch ein anderer Aspekt ist zu sagen, selbst nachzufragen bei einer Behörde, haben sie da nicht Daten? Einfach mal anzurufen und zu fragen und zu sagen, da muss es doch was geben. Wo lagert das denn bei ihnen und ist das eigentlich schon zugänglich oder würden sie das gerne zugänglich machen? Planen sie das zugänglich zu machen? Solche Fragen kann man als Bürger stellen. Also da muss man kein Hacker sein.
Ich denke auch, das muss man einfach mehrfach tun, da so einen öffentlichen Druck sozusagen erzeugen.
Oder einfach nur eine Warnhebung.
Wenn sozusagen alle Behörden sagen, ja mei, eigentlich hätte ich auch nichts dagegen, ich darf es nur gerade nicht, ich hab nur keine Gesetzesgrundlage, dann halt auch bei den Politikern zu landen. Und wenn halt der Themenpolitiker zu einem jeweiligen Thema sagt, ja mei, ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht warum, so und es dann von allen Parteien kommt, dann kann man das ja auch mal so orientiert präsentieren und sagen, hey, eigentlich habt ihr alle nichts dagegen, ihr tut es nur nicht. Und dann ist halt wirklich die Frage, wo passiert dann was?
Aber gibt es, gilt es auch noch sozusagen, so eine Art Bedürfnis zu wecken? Also ich nehme jetzt mal als wirklich hinkendes Beispiel aber mal dieses Privatsphäre-Ding. Da gibt es irgendwie viele Aktivisten, aber ein Großteil der Bevölkerung versteht einfach nicht, wozu soll das überhaupt gut sein? Also gibt es ein öffentliches Interesse an OpenData? Oder muss da auch noch was passieren?
Ich glaube, wir haben einfach noch zu wenig Dinge, die jetzt in Deutschland konkret da sind, die auch irgendwie eine große Öffentlichkeit erreicht haben, wo man dann sagen kann, okay, das hat uns irgendwie geholfen, irgendwas besser zu tun. Also insofern ist da schon auch der Aufruf da gleichzeitig. Ich glaube, dass da auch einfach der Staat teilweise auch in Vorleistung gehen muss und sagen muss, okay, wir machen jetzt hier, wir laden jetzt dazu ein. Wenn das immer sozusagen so eine halbe Konteraktion ist, dann ist es kein Wunder, dass das irgendwie irgendwann attraktiver ist zu liegen, sondern man muss da glaube ich, ja, auf der statischen Seite.
Also sag mal, glaube ich, um viele Leute zu mobilisieren, brauchst du ein Aufregerthema. Wir hatten ja auch wieder ein britisches Beispiel, da gab es so diese ganzen...
Die Briten, man, können nicht kochen, aber OpenData, geil!
Nee, ich meine, sie können auch vor allem richtig tolle Nebeneinkünfte, seltsame Nebeneinkünfte haben. Und da gab es diesen Parliament Spending Scando, wo dann der Guardian rangegangen ist. War das der Guardian? Ich glaube schon, ne? Und gesagt hat, wir haben hier eine ganze Menge Daten. Liebe User, macht da mal mit und ordnet das mal zu, guckt euch das mal an und dann konnte man auch immer mit einen hübschen Verlaufsbalken sehen auf deren Website. Okay, jetzt sind schon 7%, irgendwann waren es da 87% oder sowas. Alle schon verifiziert und zugeordnet. Das heißt, da hast du relativ viele Leute sensibilisiert für das ganze Thema. Sie haben gesehen, okay, das ist ein Aufreger für mich und haben da mitgemacht. Und da hast du dann auch irgendwann gesehen, okay, das ist jetzt open.
So, liebe Politiker, ihr dürft das nächste halbe Jahr Parteispenden annehmen, damit wir im übernächsten halben Jahr einen Skandal haben, damit wir dann OpenData an den Start bringen können. Jetzt ist ja manchmal so, dass die Gäste dieser Sendung sagen, zwei Stunden, viel zu kurz, um Gottes willen. Wir haben jetzt noch drei Minuten. Was haben wir vergessen?
Ich wollte noch fragen, habt ihr Projekte aus Berlin und Brandenburg? Oder Visualisierung, Darstellung?
Wir hatten eine...
Oder was macht der Staat in Berlin-Brandenburg? Genau.
Also was macht der Staat in Berlin-Brandenburg? Es gibt eben diese Initiative, die jetzt zusammen mit Leuten aus der Zivilgesellschaft und mit Leuten aus der Verwaltung Politik versucht, in Berlin das konkret umzusetzen. Es gibt einiges an Bewegungen in den Senatsverwaltungen, wo man überlegt, können wir, wollen wir, wann? Und da sind auch Leute dran, die das tun. Ich glaube, was denen auch weiterhelfen wird, ist, wenn von außen die Frage kommt und wenn man das auch im Wahlkampf zum Thema macht natürlich. Die Frage, wie wird in Zukunft in Berlin regiert? Wird da irgendwie transparent regiert oder wird da irgendwie hinter verschlossenen Türen gemacht?
Tatsächlich wäre natürlich so eine Ansage noch, während der Bürgermeister ist, ich veröffentliche alle Daten und das ist auch gut so. Ich glaube, diese Rückendeckung würde helfen.
Könnt ihr noch mal auf dieses Netzwerk, was ihr sagt, referenzieren, was sich da sozusagen auftut und diesen Termin, den du nanntest, am 18. Mai glaube ich, kann man da hinkommen? Ist das offen?
Da kann man hinkommen, aber ist leider voll.
Das ganze Ding heißt Berlin Open Data Day, hat einen etwas interessanten Namen Body. Das ganze Netzwerk von uns ist das Open Data Network.
Und es gibt jetzt auch zunehmend mal wieder die Bestrebung, ein paar Hackdays abzuhalten. Ich hab jetzt gerade den aktuellen Termin, ich glaube, das ist der 17. Mai. Da wird es einen Hackday, soweit ich weiß, geben zur Frage von Verkehrs.
Leute, die in diese Sendung kommen. Nee, Termin hab ich nicht im Kopf, aber ihr könnt es auf der Webseite nachschalten.
Nein, es ist der 14. Mai, weil das ist ein Samstag. 14. Mai ist ein Samstag, 18. Mai ist ein Mittwoch, an dem dieser Body stattfindet. Und der Hackday ist an dem Wochenende davor, damit die Leute, die verschiedenen Sachen nachgehen, unter der Woche vielleicht noch da ein bisschen was marken.
In der Seabase findet das statt.
Da wollte ich auch noch gleich hin.
Apropos wo gleich hin, wir sind dann gleich mal weg. Ich danke euch auf jeden Fall fürs dabei gewesen sein. Für die OpenDatas, die wir heute erfahren haben. Vielleicht werden es ein bisschen mehr in Zukunft. Viel Spaß. Wir hören uns früher wieder aber in dieser Form, also im Chaosradio, dann wieder in einem Monat, am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Den Podcast dieser Sendung, den gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz gleich. Also im Laufe der Nacht noch auf fritz.de. Später dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Da könnt ihr auch noch reichhaltig kommentieren. Dann gibt es einen Blog zur Sendung, einen Wiki, falls ihr Fragen habt oder Kommentare, könnt ihr das da alles reintragen. Damit sind wir eigentlich raus. Nach uns kommt, oder nein, doch nicht. Da ruht noch jemand tief Luftbedeutungsschwanger? Nein, alles gesagt, ausnahmsweise mal in zwei Stunden. Nach uns kommt Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight. Wird euch Punk-Musik auf die Ohren werfen, bis sie bluten. Vorher aber noch, natürlich, wie immer, am Ende dieser Sendung ein Titel, der mir und euch sehr ans Herz gewachsen ist. Website mit Dragan Espenschied von Trekkie Birthday. Und mir bleibt da nur noch eins zu sagen. Vielen Dank euch und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und macht immer schön eure Backups.